welcome everyone the time
being
9:39 we will get started I apologize for
the late start I found my tire to be low
and had to get it pumped up didn't plan
on that this
morning okay first up we'll invite uh
15 thank you Mr chairman good morning
and now that your tires pumped up let me
get you pumped up to protect the
taxpayers
um uh I'm Jason Osborne I represent uh
towns of
Auburn Candia and
Deerfield is my pleasure to bring to you
this morning uh uh
cacr uh 15 so this
um amendment is uh an attempt I guess to
uh to solidify New Hampshire's uh status
as a as a beacon of of freedom and low
taxes and and all the good things that
Americans hold dear
um we at uh because we know
um I'll just reach for my sheet here
look with with a provision like this in
place ens shrin in our constitution we
can rest easy with the knowledge the
granite Staters can feel conf confident
that we will remain income and sales tax
uh free you know like to say that uh low
taxes are uh the result of low spending
but I think um uh the way things work in
a state like New Hampshire that it's
kind of the opposite that uh that low
spending is the result of the restraint
imposed by uh low taxes uh I think uh a
former speaker said it to me uh this way
that we spend all the money that we have
so we can uh uh prevent the finance
committee down down the hall from having
more money to spend than they than they
won't
um so uh what I was surprised to find
out uh because when I put this in I
didn't realize that this was already
such a uh a popular uh thing across this
country there are actually 14 other
states uh that have this uh uh provision
in their constitutions and there are uh
all different kinds of States there's
giant States there's very tiny States
there's red States there's blue States
there's High tax states there's low tax
states and uh so while I I thought of
a
anti-tax uh kind of proposal it it
doesn't seem to be that that's the case
in the real world and uh to me this um
not so much about tax policy but it's
about uh consent you know the
Declaration of Independence says that
the just powers of government are
derived from the consent of the
government and I I I may
be uh in the alone in this room in being
able to Envision an alternate universe
where the functions of government are
funded on a voluntary transactional
basis rather than by uh course of
Taxation but in this real world
[Music]
um it
uh it's not a stretch to imagine that we
can increase the level of consent from a
simple majority to a super majority
because we can look around this country
and more than 25% of the states are
already doing it that way so uh it's my
hope that we can give this gift to the
uh people of the Granite State um in
November and allow them uh to vote on
adding this provision to the uh
Constitution and I'll go ahead and cut
it short but I'll I'll hand in my notes
Here uh for you to put on file if you
like uh I'm happy to take questions I
don't know that I'll have answers but
I'd be happy to you know take the
homework assignment with me and and send
you back what I find out thank you do we
have any questions representative Aly
would you mind giving us the list of the
for
States and also
um
[Music]
to let me
see can't remember the other thing this
point okay uh so the states include I
don't know if this is a complete list
but it's a Arizona Arkansas California
Delaware Florida
Kentucky
okay gotta so maybe you just you
I'll pass it okay yes representative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question on
line 24 of this bill page
one says the Senate uh House of
Representative Senate shall be required
to pass a new tax if a two-thirds vote
is needed what if the state has an
emergency that requires Bond and tax
action to resolve the emergency would
this law negate action by the
legislature
uh from acting well I think in an
emergency situation you'd have no
problem getting a two-thirds vote of the
legislature so there are other states
that um require uh tax increases to
actually go to the ballot uh for the
people to vote on and and I think that
that's even that's a step too far like
as much as I'm in favor of the consent
of the government I think you gotta you
got to allow the government to to
operate and and I think uh I think this
is a happy uh medium thank you follow up
Mr chairman follow up uh on the second
page lines uh starting with line five or
start with line
four it talks
about uh the
revenue is
there a priority order of distribution
of State funds if we couldn't get the
2third vote for this emergency
or I do believe that's uh up to the
finance committee to decide how the
no I will withdraw my
answer thank you representative
ery yeah to follow up on that we have a
provision that says that bonded funds
will be paid period they're the first
priority which then goes over to the
finance committee if I'm not or fiscal
committee if I'm not mistaken to shift
funds around in in order to meet this
obligation meet this obligation or tell
somebody that they're not going to go to
work next week um and if a crisis
arrives the question then becomes if
change well I think you would be the one
that I would ask that question to it
sounds
[Laughter]
like uh representative
fellows so this is another question
about the bonds so a bond means that the
state borrowed a large amount of money
for an extended period of time and
making payments on that Bond or like a
mortgage making the interest payments
so what I'm concerned about what the
consequences are if you don't um make
your bond payments for sure your rating
is going to go down but um I think that
that is really a big problem to say that
we need a 2third vote to make bond
payments which are normally just
something that's included in the
budget well I I think your concern is
valid and I share your concern I'm
pretty sure that um over two-thirds of
your colleagues would share that concern
too so I'm not sure that this would be
an impediment again the U you know 14
so yes repres
PL uh There's no distinction about size
of tax or fee so this would apply to a
$2 increase on a say a motor vehicle fee
or something like that I do believe that
it would and uh the lower the fee the
easier it'll be to get two-thirds to
it uh represent
Jo thank you um I'm wondering if you
have inquired of the state treasurer or
the bond rating agencies or the major
sources of bonds as to the effect of a
requirement like this on uh the price
the effective price that the state will
have to pay for um raising money uh
through
bonding uh no I have not I I like that
question and I will look into that
representative Aly yeah I've still got a
question here or a comment in a question
on the fiscal committee does may
eventually on on agree or not but it is
the governor that decides in cases of
major emergencies who is going to get
what and who is going to have nothing
and um that that is has been the fact in
our government at least as long as I've
been here which is almost 30 years now
um is that a would you believe would you
would you believe that that uh this
actually puts a huge amount of power
into the hands of the governor when we
get to emergency and we've just been
through
one I I would believe and I do uh share
your concern about the emergency powers
of the executive branch and uh whichever
part
right could I have a follow sure follow
yes the other um uh problem that I see
with this um and I wonder if you have
considered the fact that we have been
dumping um needs and costs onto the
towns and the property tax by removing
taxes for some time now and that this
would would uh
allow
towns and cities to have and counties to
have to to raise their property taxes in
order to replace
Services yeah I I I get the concern but
I've what I have observed is that the
more uh money we send to the towns and
the cities it doesn't seem to prevent
them from continuing to raise their
taxes and um I know that um
I wouldn't expect a town to uh treat the
state's money um the same as they treat
their own just the same as I don't
expect that the state treats Federal
money uh the same as their own so I I I
don't I don't see the property tax
connection as uh
being
um a concern here representative
spillsbury thank you Mr chairman uh
would you be satisfied If the percentage
was 35th 60% instead of two3 yeah I
think any movement uh toward greater
consent is good I mean I'd be happier
with 80% but um you know 2/3 is um is a
number that we see in other states so I
I think that's it gives people a a sense
of of comfort that you know it's not
it's not an outrageous number and it's
not
uh yeah it was interesting to me as
you're going through your list one of
the States you mentioned was California
and high tech State and yet they I think
they're on this list correct right I
gotta tell you I I I was shocked from
going from when I when I when I put this
in what I my preconceptions were to uh
you know what actually exists in the in
the real world was yeah kind kind of
kind of different yeah I wouldn't have
ECT of that representative fellows um I
know that on the local level um there
are tax
caps which is a little different than
this but they're tax caps but they allow
their caps like to not exceed the rate
of inflation so I'm wondering if any of
these states that have this provision
and you're saying they have it in their
constitution their state constitution do
do they have any except
for inflation so I think the tax rates
are not the problem it's more the fees I
mean we had a bill on camping fees you
know do we have to have a that hadn't
been increased in many years I mean it
just seems kind
of no but I I don't imagine that You'
need to have that in the Constitution
right you could you could uh when you
create your fee you could build into it
a um esal alation that could be uh so
you vote on at one time and then it
continues to escalate over time right
follow up so are you saying like when we
have fees in the rsas camping fees that
there should be some provision in that
statute that said says allowed to in
can't allowed to
increase by the rate of inflation yeah I
I'm saying you could if if that's what
and then how would how would because
constitutional is going to overrule
anything that's in the RSA right but if
you if so you got a fee and you say it's
a dollar this year and it increases by
50% 50 cents per year you vote on it
with a two-thirds vote then it's
just it's kind of on autopilot at that
point
right yeah it's interesting you bring up
the towns in their tax caps because uh
something we see is that um the the
towns just ignore the tax caps and they
do whatever they want and uh uh same way
uh in the state of Washington they don't
have a constitutional provision but they
have had six separate ballot initiatives
to impose a two-thirds requirement on
their legislature and they just ignore
it it's like it doesn't
exist so that that's why that's why it
needs to go in the Constitution and not
just be because we can't
impose
U uh a requirement ourselves on a future
legislature
representative elberger thank you Mr
chairman and I have questions in two
areas if I may
okay uh we have a couple of lawsuits
that have been uh successfully argued in
lower court now are being appealed by
the state regarding funding for public
education if
the uh lawsuit prevails at a higher
level how will
how would you
foresee uh raising the funds necessary
to
support uh public education at the
required
level right uh I again if if we're
talking about an issue that is that
important I I don't see that it would be
a problem to overcome the two-thirds
requirement okay and second
question in the light of um wanting
fiscal uh responsibility and
transparency would you also agree that
any tax cuts or eliminations would have
to be approved by 2third of the bar of
the
bodies well no I mean um if you wanted
to have the mirror image of the
two-thirds requirement it should really
only take onethird um
to uh cut or eliminate ATT tax right
because the idea
is consent but but I I I do think you do
need a little bit you know of
of resistance in the in the downward
Direction so I I think you know 50% to
uh to decrease the taxes is not not a
horrible place to be you have a question
yes repres
Aly thank you on when we passed the
original education funding money it took
us 8
hours without a break locked in and we
went back and forth and back and forth
and we just barely passed it if I
remember correctly there is no way we
could have gotten
2/3 and that would you believe
that I I would believe onethird is not a
majority in a democracy 2third is a very
large de a majority in our elections
half is just barely getting you
there um is that a question that's a
that's a yeah uh but I think in in
elections of Representatives that's a a
different kind of a story and you uh if
you needed two-thirds to elect a
representative you would end up in a
situation where you didn't have a
representative but I think when we're
talking about uh the act of taking a
portion of someone's property or income
that I think a very high level of
consent should be required for
that that's why I put this
in anybody else yes representative ORS
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question a followup on rep um
alberger question about what about tax
reduction so and your opinion over the
years as we have reduced taxes has it
increased revenue does it remain the
same
do we do we lose Revenue to a point
where it becomes a
problem I I I think our observation uh
up to this point is that it uh revenues
have increased over time okay and so is
there some way you could provide
followup thank you uh would you be able
to provide us with proof of that do we
have that I mean I like the theory but
do we have proof of that in New
Hampshire is my question uh if if you
would like me to go do that homework I
can do that but um I'm pretty sure you
you know the answer Yeah well yeah say I
I would not but I mean maybe Dr or
somebody could show us that so uh
followup one more followup okay so if if
representative alberger question about
you know what would it take to reduce
taxes I think we could agree that at
least a 50% plus one vote might be
enough to reduce
you all
right thank you very much thank
you your notes please thank
you all right next up I have uh Greg
Prosperity good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity speak here today for the
record my name is Greg Moore I am a
regional director with Americans for
Prosperity uh cacr 15 as you see it is
not a particularly novel piece of
legislation uh veteran members of this
committee have seen this on many
occasions uh I see represent really
waving at me because he's he himself has
brought this legislation on several
occasions including in 2011 which was my
first experience with this type of
amendment uh which is when it passed the
house of represent resentatives a little
bit of History then is that 2011 it it
really only included uh in its first
iteration the parts on page one as well
as uh the voter guide components it came
out of this committee uh oop pass didn't
didn't get a majority I mean it got a
majority but didn't achieve the required
uh three- fifth majority in the house
came back to this committee had this the
the second component which is at the to
the top of page two uh which was
language that was provided by the state
treasurer to order to ensure that the
state's Bonds were protected in order to
protect the State's bond rating because
otherwise without that uh provision they
felt as though it would be represent a
threat to uh the State's bond rating so
that was added uh at the behest of
several several members who had that
concern raised by the state treasurer uh
we believe this is important legislation
to send a signal to the to the uh rest
of the the region and the country that
New Hampshire is going to remain a low
tax Beacon
uh Provisions like this uh there was a a
study by the uh the Journal of public uh
economists that found that low tax
states to P pass Super majority
Provisions does have the effect of
ensuring low taxes going forward uh on
the other hand uh Provisions like this
also exist in in such notorious low tax
states as Rhode Island California and
Hawaii uh where obviously the the the
provision is not necessarily limiting
their ability to to uh raise taxes as
needed I would say that I would say that
this is this is important legislation to
send that clear signal uh across across
the region across a country that New
Hampshire is going to remain a low tax
state and ultimately uh we will uh
produce positive results for our economy
and economic growth going forward
because as as particularly as employers
understand that there's going to be that
level of tax certainty they become even
more inclined to want to come to a state
like that further enhancing our economic
growth over the long Arc of it uh so
with that I'd be happy to take any
questions uh talk about my experience
this is probably so working for the
house I had a chance to go through this
once and I've been to this committee
probably two or three times since then
in the intervening 11 years since I left
the House of Representatives so I'd be
happy to take any questions thank you
representative fellows thank you
um representative Osborne told us that
there are I think he said 14 states that
have this in their constitution but a
lot of them just ignored can you explain
the part about how they ignore it uh so
I think he referenced specifically the
state of Washington the state of
Washington has
put you know we're we are not a a ballot
referendum question the only thing that
goes on the ballot for us our
constitutional amendments we don't have
like state of Massachusetts which
actually can can pass laws via ballot
referenda uh the state of Washington has
that same provision like Massachusetts
and may have passed what amounts to
state laws via ballot referendum six
times now as you know no legislature or
in this case the public can uh do
anything that can compel a future
legislature to anything so while that
law goes on the books a future
legislature comes along ignores the law
and then turns around and passes uh
passes a tax increase regardless of the
fact that there was something on the
books saying that it would require super
majority and they don't they do it
without a super majority because as you
know uh representative you can put a put
a provision and say uh regardless of RSA
whatever this or notwithstanding any any
other provision of law to the contrary
you can do this uh and he is right there
are 14 states that have these Provisions
specifically within their constitution
and then there are two others uh the
states of Colorado and uh the state of
Missouri that actually require tax
increases to go on the ballot uh so
really there's 16 states that that have
somewhat similar provisions like this
that that uh create this sort of uh
increased bar Beyond just a simple
majority in in the legislature I'm sorry
does that answer your question followup
um partly but so I'm starting to see
some differentiation here so I totally
understand we ignore we ignore rsay all
the time but that's not the same as
ignoring something that's in the
Constitution
so how many states actually have this in
their con state constitution so what did
do they have exactly these words uh
there are varying levels uh excuse me
anywhere between 3- fifths and 34s so
2/3 is sort of like in the middle
between the two in the constitution in
the Constitution uh I I do have an
example for you uh relative to a state
that that uh ignored what was in their
con Constitution the state of Oregon had
a provision like this in in their
constitution but then there was a ruling
a judicial ruling that found that base
broadening activities were did were not
included so in other words so in other
words which I think most of us agreed
that if you broaden a base of attacks
that would be a tax increase but the
state of Oregon uh had went through a
judicial ruling where their Supreme
Court actually indicated that they could
do Bas broadening with without
implicating the uh super majority so
that's another example of a state that
basically found a shortcut around the
elberger thank you Mr chairman when you
talk about low tax state are you
including property taxes in that uh
decision if you include property taxes
New Hampshire is still a low tax state
so the answer is yes uh
that that we have um relatively High
property taxes uh compared to other
states does not actually change the fact
that including state and local tax
burden New Hampshire is still one of the
lowest tax burdens in the nation and
there are other states the states that
are higher than us on property tax
states like Illinois and States like New
Jersey obviously have a full array of
other taxes that we
don't followup
followup I'm going to use this as a
would you believe uh the New York Times
every Sunday in its real estate
section uh looks at different property
country um in last June I happened to be
in New York and picked up a copy they
were comparing $400,000 properties in
three different parts of the country
Denver Washington DC and some community
in New Hampshire and I apologize I don't
remember which it was the would you
believe believe that the property taxes
in Denver and Washington were $4,000 a
year and $6,000 a year while the
property in New
Hampshire
was 140 no I'm sorry
$40,000 for the
year and I apologize for the fact that I
have this big speaker in my face that's
I can't actually look at you when I'm
talking to you uh sure I I would believe
that uh I would I would say that that uh
one of the things that that uh it's
important to consider is that in a state
where property taxes uh make up a
significant portion of the overall State
and uh state state and local tax burden
is that there can be wide variations
within communities and so there are high
tax High relatively High tax communities
and and relatively low tax communities I
think what that gives much like the
opportunity for people to vote with
their feet among states is people can
vote with their feet among communities
as well um follow up follow up and and a
correction I apologize it's a big
correction it's $14,000 not 40 that
um would you believe I know let's let's
play games here that while New Hampshire
is among the top 10 states in terms of
public support for public education
depending on which research you look at
we are either next to last or dead last
in terms of State support for public
you representative shamberg thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Moore for taking
this question concerning on page two
lines one through uh 7 about the
appropriation for payment of Interest
first of all this is for it wouldn't be
for for
any it is based on the present Bond
issues that have been issued correct
it's a
past past
wording so this language is
substantially similar to language that
was added in 2011 to the to the
Constitutional Amendment and maybe
represent y can correct me I think it
was cicr 10 I think it was I don't know
it's you know a while back um and this
was a language that was provided
specific speically by the state
treasurer so the state treasurer
actually actually drafted this language
and and and offered it to this committee
that that added it in to the legislation
and I think I could go back to check
that the language but I'm pretty sure
that this is word for verbatim word for
word what the state treasure offered to
to this committee okay follow up Mr
chairman follow up well the second part
of this is from line four through line
five it talks about the the state
treasurer being able to uh set apart
from the first general fund revenues
thereafter received a sum sufficient to
pay such interest or installments of
principles if the legislature does
not by a 2third
vote approve any more bonds or approve
any payment that would cover the bond
issues the state treasur takes
over would this not create havoc on the
budget of the state for those that are
all Downstream if the treasur is making
the the decision to pull this money
without
consultation uh
or with the legislature yeah you can
tell the state treasurer wrote this
provision huh yes uh no I I I I I
understand um I think that's why why
they wanted it in the constitution is
because because the um the state
treasury it would be constitutionally
directed to do that as as opposed and
and the legislature would then therefore
have to work around the fact that the
that the treasurer's hands were tied and
uh and and again I this this shows why
but but but I also I'm also cognizant of
the fact that that any state treasurer
understands that they are elected by the
legislature so I think that I think that
you're going to get a fair degree of
consultation throughout this process as
a result of it but but to your to your
broader Point yes the treasur is
directed to do that um first and
foremost and then and then the
legislature is going to have to adjust
to what the treasurer would do based
responsibilities all right seeing no
you and that is it for the pink cards I
have
um all right I will close the public
1116 thank
you and representative Sweeny will
introduce the
bill
than thank thank you Mr chairman members
of the Ways and Means Committee um I
think when we think about the reasons
people send us to conquer uh this bill
isn't one of them uh this is a very uh
housekeeping bill that house election
law committee had amended the original
bill I will say that the copy of the
bill that's over there is the originally
introduced version there was an
amendment in election law that was
unanimously supported and then it was
unanimously supported on the the house
floor uh the current bill as amended
after house election law simply removes
the $2 fee for state repres
representative candidates um that was
the policy that the house election law
committee uh decided to and since it
does technically affect revenue streams
uh for the
municipalities uh that's why it's before
you here today uh for house Ways and
Means again it's just removing the $2
filing fee for state representative
candidates to get on the ballot um I
think speaking for one of the larger
towns that will be impacted by this uh
fee I I would you know if there's upset
at Town Hall I'll gladly pay the $36
that they typically anticipate every two
years uh for this fee um but I'm happy
to take any questions about how the
election law committee got to that point
uh with just eliminating the $2 fee uh
but that really is uh you know I think
less than
$10,000 of uh is is generous uh for this
bill's Revenue impact when it's just
every two-year fee so thank you any
questions yes represent elberger thank
you Mr chairman just curious I assume
that this uh set of fees and the
increases would not be required to get
two-thirds approval no and so and the
bill was amended in election law so
there's no fee increases in the bill it
this is the older version of the bill as
I stated the current legislation just
eliminates the $2 fee for state
representatives nothing else happens
thank
you and it just representative it's not
yeah it's just state representative all
right so even actually a town of Sal
would be $18 yeah right 9 time 2 so it's
yeah pretty
minor uh anyone
else all right seeing none thank you all
good all right um I will close the
hp16 okay thank you Mr chairman yes U
could we ask that the amended version be
circulated for the full
committee the
amended the amended version of what HB
the version as amended by election law
and adopted on the house floor is the
one that we actually need to consider
and so when we meet for executive
session I'd like to have seen that okay
so what do so we have I think this is
amended the one we have
back
yeah we do have the amended
[Music]
versionary yes um what representative
Sweeney was saying was that basically on
page one that lines 11 through 15 are
not present
anymore
lines yes to clarify on the table all
I'm seeing is the original version and
the fiscal note okay the wrong version
must be on the table then
we when they first passed this out
um and we got all the bills that's
that's the one that um I think we got
amended I don't yeah I'm not sure why
there um I just before I forget I just
want to make an announcement about are
you closing this hearing I already
closed
ago um you want to get
cop I took it off the internet oh you
did well it should no I have a copy
very well the copies that were all
handed out whenever that was maybe the
January yeah so do
I
okay um I just want to make an
announcement on
scheduling um yesterday I said we would
schedule Monday and Tuesday um
of each week in February except the last
week which is school vacation week um
next week it is going to be Monday and
Tuesday it'll be coming out in in the
calendar um 10 o'clock start each day um
but the following week which
is uh the week of the
12th um that no wait a minute let me let
memorized
and yeah well next week what I just said
on about five and 6 is correct um Monday
and Tuesday we'll be starting each day
at 10 o'cl uh the following week the
12th and the 13th um I'm not sure Monday
I don't know I should know by the end of
the day today or tomorrow whether Monday
is going to work it might be the 13th
and the 14th on that week so I just
wanted to let you know now I'm sorry I
don't have that definitive it's either
going to be 12th and the 13th or the
13th and the 14th of February and I and
I hopefully we'll have an answer um by
tomorrow I'll I'll send an email out um
I don't know about 10:00 a.m. or 9:30
you know it's going to be um but other
than that the 19th and the 20th Monday
and Tuesday um should be fine it's it's
just an issue with that week of the 12th
14 could I ask how long you think you're
going to be going on the
fence because I don't I get out of the
dentist about uh
12:15 how far away is your dentist so is
it in your town it's in my town it's
bit so I've
got
one two three four five six seven eight
there's eight eight bills in a work
session starting at 10 o'clock on Monday
I purposely did not include your bill on
Monday 1492 thank you um so 1492 will be
the first one on Tuesday at 10
o'clock um so right now the well what
I've submitted and what will come out of
the calendar is eight Bills starting at
10 o'clock for a work session on Monday
the 5th Tuesday the 6th there'll be six
bills in a work session followed by
that's at 10 and then a one o00 start to
an exec session of all those bills of
Monday and Tuesday now I know I don't
know that we can get through all those
but the the way it works is I'm allowed
to list all these so in case it goes
fast we don't want to run out um the
more we can get done the better um so
when you see the calendar don't get
frighten they we're going to be here
till midnight because we'll we'll cut it
we'll be cutting it off
um so do you if you know those Bill
numbers already can you just make a copy
of that so we'll know the calendar won't
come out until
Friday um it comes out an email on
Thursday
night um well it's
um yeah I have an e well um I have an
email that I could forward
yeah okay Mr chairman yeah I believe the
bills for Monday will be the ones that
we had hearings on on the 9th and
16th and the bills for Tuesday are then
the bills we had hearings on for the
17th so if you just look at those
agendas you'll see the list that's a
good point if you still have the public
hearing uh so we our first public
hearing so we had public hearings on the
9th and the 16th those are the first two
public hearings we
had all those bills will be in the work
1492 Mr chairman I can still phot an
email later yes I I get Torn
Between the the efforts that you're
making to be respectful of Outsiders
time with regard to scheduling bills
yeah I'm wondering though since there
has been so much variation in how long
some of our hearings are whether it
might make sense to consider scheduling
all of the hearings at the same time so
that we aren't left with chunks of time
waiting until the next bill that we're
supposed to hear okay so um the public
hearings have to have a an absolute time
for example the next public hearings at
uh HB 1054 starts at 10:30 I cannot
start it earlier it has to start at
10:30 but once we start doing work so at
the end of the day
today we'll be done with all the public
hearings of the bills in Ways and Means
starting Monday we'll start doing work
sessions the work sessions all I have to
do is start with an initial time it'll
say 10 o'clock there'll be a whole list
of bills if we finish one we just go to
the next one we don't have to yeah and
and because when you see it it's a long
list we'll just automatically break for
long we're not going to get all this
done in the morning morning so we'll
break for lunch you know at the
appropriate time whether it's 12:00 or
12:30 depending on how we're progressing
um we'll have lunch and then we'll
continue yes represent Omi uh two two
questions uh one on if you're you're
normally I think going to go in the
order that the bills are listed I'm
going to go I've decided to go in the
order of the bills as we've done the
public hearings yeah um and that way the
nice thing about that is they get
grouped in some sort of fashion as well
originally I was thinking about trying
to do the easier ones first then I said
well it's
just that doesn't make any sense because
if we hit a hard one where we need
another work session or need more
information then we know in advance
instead of waiting pushing it off too
far so you aren't attempting to to exec
all of the bills next week and leave us
with
nothing oh no no because next week we
we're going to have work sessions on oh
I see you're saying because I don't need
a work I'm trying to do a work session
on every single bill yeah um and some of
them might be as simple as we don't have
any questions I open the work session we
talk for one two minutes and I close the
work session and move on to the next
one but there there will be occasions
when somebody uh a sponsor will look at
it on Friday and say I want to be there
but I've got a
conflict and try to call you up maybe
and see if he could be moved to a
different yeah I mean I can skip you
know if it makes sense I can skip over
that one and schedule it the following
week so
okay so we're also we're going we're not
going to try and exact every bill on
Tuesday afternoon I mean two I'm going
to list um so there's bills on Monday
work sessions there's six work sessions
on Tuesday that's 14 I then listed all
14 for an exec session I don't think we
can will make it through all 14 although
some of them may be um we just it
doesn't make sense to exec it so we just
skip over it and so this long list just
all thank you and we will not be excting
any Monday
you
12 12 it's usually 1 hour so it's 12:15
I don't know why it takes
drive
all right in an effort to stay on track
we'll get
10:31
we'll excuse me um I want to call things
here all
right um I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB 1054
and uh we'll
call Christine Wellington to uh
introduce the
bill I'm the prime sponsor rep Ali
Murray oh sorry about that okay I don't
have a pin card from you then okay I'll
I'll bring that over after um thank you
Mr chair and honorable members of the
committee for the record my name is
alisandra Murray and I represent Ward 9
in
Manchester um last year when the house
passed our state budget we included non
colling funding for a new border uh
northern border Alliance program this
provision was originally removed by the
majority of Representatives when the
bill passed through the house but was
added back in um when it went to the
other side of the wall the northern
border Alliance provides grants to law
enforcement agencies for the purpose of
reducing potential legal activity within
25 miles of the Canadian border the bill
before you now does something very
simple it changes the current non-aps in
function of this fund so that in the
future this program would be funded
through the typical budget appropriation
process this change is necessary for a
couple reasons one being that the
legislature was clearly divided on this
funding when it was originally passed
the second is that the need for the
funding was tied to a lack of federal
funds and the federal funding we
received can fluctuate year to year and
the legislature should be able to adjust
the appropriation as those circumstances
change and thirdly there's little to no
publicly available data to indicate any
kind of crisis at the border of New
Hampshire and Canada and the US Customs
and Border Protection already has a
strong presence there um so that's my
introduction I'm happy to answer any
questions but also there are some folks
here who are better versed on this
subject thank you do we have a question
yes represent El me yeah just um a
matter of fact you might be able to tell
us it says in close proximity now to the
Canadian border um the border patrol
used to go come down 100 miles to
Lebanon and I'm just wondering where did
you get 25 miles from well this is in
regards to the um program that's funding
our local police and that's only
applicable to within 25 miles the US
Customs and Border Patrol does Patrol
within the 100 miles of that's in law
somewhere
you no other questions okay oh you have
a question represent yeah I'm just I I
can't remember I'm not sure can you tell
me where the money comes from is this a
state appropriation or federal money or
both it's state money from my knowledge
yeah thank you yes
represent well if it's Federal
money it's state state money okay that
uh that do changes my question okay if
it's state money and it becomes non-aps
that would mean that there would
essentially be an increase each year in
in the budget because or budget
expenditures because instead of having a
pool of resources here and then just
fill in what it else is necessary to
bring up the expense costs to the level
needed we would be funding the entire
thing over again is that correct I'm I'm
not sure I understand are you saying
that if there's like residual ual funds
from year to year that we wouldn't we
explain yeah currently it's
[Music]
non-aps you're changing it to lapsing so
if it's
lapsing the money the the third year
into the operation the money would go
back to the general fund mhm and then
the entire program would have to be
refunded from zero
each year instead of being able to draw
on a reserve of un unexpended funds so
there would be a gap of time where there
was no funds available is that correct I
see what you're saying I mean I think
that the Gap I don't know that the Gap
would exist because it would align with
our budgetary process um and if you know
the money is lapsing back into the
general funds anyway the money is still
thank you representative Aly uh yeah uh
would would you believe that being on
dedicated funds I know having looked
into this uh that uh they uh that all of
the funds that are funded this way on if
the if necessary move to negative
positions in the treasury and are paid
for once the budget is
finished I would believe
[Laughter]
questions I guess I I have just a
general question you said there's no
problem at the northern border um from
what I've read the number of uh
potential illegal Crossings have
increased three-fold over the past year
um at least three-fold um so the there's
OB and we know at the southern border we
have a huge um
uh issue down there so I mean shouldn't
I gu I guess my concern or my question
is where does you're saying there's no
no concern but we're seeing changes
shouldn't we be ready to respond in a
way where we don't have to um rely on a
budgeting process every year um thank
you Mr chair for your question um I I
would say that the publicly available
data relating to Crossings of the
Canadian border is largely not New
Hampshire specific and there has been no
data made available to the public um
even with multiple right to know
requests for this data on the amount of
Crossings on specifically the New
Hampshire Canadian border which is a
very small part of the actual Canadian
border um so this isn't really a New
Hampshire problem that we should be our
T taxpayers should be taking the burden
of this is Vermont's issue this is
Maine's issue it's not our issue and I
think that um as I said before um part
of the reasoning for this uh funding
originally was uh cited to be a lack of
federal funds and that's going to change
from year to year and I think that we
should be able to adjust the amount that
we put into this program year toe based
on those changes or you know by by
annually thank you yes representative
ORS thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question so as somebody
already said I believe the border
crossings last year alone exceeded 10
years of border crossings and recently
we had a mass murderer found in Rye and
knowing that the last group I believe
that was caught coming over the Border
were Mexicans you don't see a problem on
our border from people south of our
country um again I would say that that
data regarding the 300% increase is not
New Hampshire specific data and it's not
about specifically crossings from can
Canada into New Hampshire so it
shouldn't be our funding going to solve
other states problems and I would say
that um in those situations that you
named the border patrol did their job
because those people were apprehended um
without this program in
existence follow up so I didn't mention
anything about a 300% increase I said
over the years we've exceeded 10 years
growth however it is our problem if we
have me Mexicans Brazilians whoever
doesn't matter who they are coming over
our border why why is our border why is
it Vermont's problem and Maine's problem
but not our problem if we have these
people including a mass murder coming
into our country I mean it's I don't
understand your position I'm not aware
of any other program we fund to deal
with problems that happen in other
states it's it's not another followup
it's not a
a different State's it's our problem
they're coming over our
border we'll um we can discuss this in a
work session thank you um did you have a
question representative
ellerie uh yes um what two three weeks
ago the national Hospitality Association
put on a program right here in conquer
regarding uh human trafficking and its
effect um are you aware that during that
presentation they indicated that the
number of people coming across the New
Hampshire border engaged in human
trafficking had increased something like
threefold and the number of arrests had
decreased due to lack of
enforcement are you aware of that
information from the national
Hospitality Association I was not pres
at that event so I wasn't aware of that
information thank
you represent fellows uh thank you uh
this is technical so I'm not sure if you
know the answer to it I'm wondering if
if this is is this a dedicated fund now
is if it's a dedicated fund then and
we're going to essentially move it to be
pretty much the same as like any any
regular Fund in the budget if it needs
to be in a different place in the
rsas I'm not 100% sure but I believe it
is a dedicated fund maybe I'm sure
somebody else will probably know the
answer to that thank you I mean the
thing we do know is it's non-lps at the
present
time does that mean it's in would well
my question do we need to move it
because it's non-aps or is the r can it
be in the same
that the the dedicated funds are spread
all over the rsas they only appear
together in
612 and I don't know whether this one is
612 or not we haven't done safety for a
while all right all right thank you
representative sham oh well
representative shamberg and then we'll
go to yeah right okay right thank you Mr
chair uh to you Mr chairman will we be
hearing from any state local or County
officials today on this bill um I don't
know I have uh three pin cards here
we'll see um
have if we need to we can hear you know
during a work session as well represent
Aly yes uh did you know that Senator
Shaheen has asked for the information
the breakdown of the information it's
New
York Vermont New Hampshire Maine on and
it's all in one group and she has asked
for it I think five times now and has
never gotten an answer so I doubt very
much that New Hampshire Hospitality was
using anything except the state the
national the four state statistic is
that who was that a question for too was
that a did you know I did not know thank
you all right anything
else thank you thank
you and if you'd fill out a pink card I
appreciate it all right next I have uh
Wellington oh thank you sorry about that
um Mr chair and members of the committee
I'm Christine Wellington I'm a um I live
in Dairy and um my colleague G Grace
Kandi is also here with me um and she
has also filled out a pink card to talk
about and hopefully fill in some of the
um questions about um uh this bill um
before you continue let's just have
Grace introduce herself thank you Mr
chairman my name is Grace kand I am the
program coordinator with the American
friend service committee so thank you
for taking our testimony
today I sent you an email from our group
The New Hampshire immigrants rights
Network um early evening uh yesterday
that that uh explains in detail some of
the questions folks have had um and and
we support
uh uh changing the funding from non-aps
to an evidencebased
um program that goes through the um
normal budgetary process um it's our
opinion that this this uh program the
um border Alliance is not based on any
um data that would support the
expenditure of $1.4 million on a yearly
basis we've communicated with the
Department of Safety about this and had
had very productive conversations about
their plans but we still feel that um
there's uh no real basis for this as as
um representative Murray said this our
border is 53 miles we're part of a um a
sector called the Swanton sector and
it's true that in Vermont and um New
York State the part of New York state
that is um uh part of the Swan sector
there have been great increases um we've
had a difficulty getting any data about
the actual Crossings into to New
Hampshire but one of our other
colleagues today has just gotten um the
actual data and and and he will also uh
be testifying I believe he's put in a
card now uh be on that from the um
ACLU um so the other thing is that there
are uh there's a a strong presence of
federal border enforcement agents um in
the North country and the other uh
factor that we really wanted the the
committee to know is that New Hampshire
already receives federal funds for many
aspects of of security and
anti-terrorism and border security
through the stone garden program New
Hampshire's been receiving operation
stone garden federal funds um for over
10 years um at Le at least since uh
2011 and uh the last funding Grant uh
was
$200,000 those are based on applications
where you have to establish why you need
the money um and so those are
evidence-based and that's what the the
feds decided to give New Hampshire to
work with the federal agents at the
border to help secure the Border but
fundamentally we believe that this is a
federal issue that the federal programs
are staffed and are uh supported and I
think that's uh really what our message
is today and Grace uh will add some
other
details so thank you to the committee um
what I wanted to add was in addition to
being a part of um as of this Coalition
um that is focused on um really putting
some guard rails on on this on this
particular program our organization has
also worked very closely during the
budget cycle as part of what we call the
New Hampshire people's budget campaign
in order to ensure that public dollars
are going into programs that are most
needed for New Hampshire people and so
last year when this um when this line
item was included in the budget um we
were very disheartened because again as
my colleague has said there was very
little data to support it and instead
there was a lot of rhetoric
um that really was uh focused on
immigrant communities and really this
idea that immigrant communities are
harmful are others are sort of these
alien species that are coming to invade
New Hampshire and with the lack of data
what we were seeing was an increase in
dis in the sense of not belonging of
discomfort um and really pitting New
Hampshire communities against one
another and so as our Coalition has been
able to do we have been able to visit
the North Country to speak to directly
with North Country residents to
understand more deeply what is actually
needed for folks who are living um in
the topmost half of our state and what
was clear is that people needed access
to broadband they needed more in
Investments and resources into mental
health and Recovery treatment services
and instead what our legislature decided
to do was to increase the fund to put
funding towards a program that was not
asked for that was based on faulty data
and that was not being responsive to
what New Hampshire communities are were
asking for and are actually in need of
and so there have been there were
wonderful things that were passed in the
last year's budget that we were very
proud to see and that would certainly do
a do a lot and go a long way into
helping um New Hampshire communities in
order to live and Thrive and work and go
to school here in ways that build up
their lives and so there is very what we
have seen in the work that we've done is
that there are no there are very few if
any other programs that are both
initially started in funded without any
sort of guardrail um any sort of uh
expectation to assess the um the the uh
how well the program is running before
simply just automatically renewing those
funds every year and so this legislation
is an attempt to put some clear um
parameters around is this program
working because we know it wasn't needed
in the first place so is this program
even needed and I think it's really
important in order for this for this
legislature to be good stewards of New
Hampshire Public money of taxpayer
dollars to ensure that we are putting
into place uh true parameters that says
okay if we are going to allocate this
much money we are going to do so in a
way that does not automatically renew it
and we know already that it is clear
that this money could be used elsewhere
where people really truly need it
especially our North Country
residents happy to take
PL this country is built from immigrants
my grandparents came over but they came
over following law you see no difference
between people coming over following law
and just coming over with with without
any uh any any uh any process of law so
what I want to say I'm also an immigrant
representative I came here as a toddler
on a plane and so I to your point also
came in under what is considered like
what I got into line right but as an
advocate for immigration what I have
seen over and over and over again and
have directly experience myself because
even though I came here technically
legally I became undocumented and lived
undocumented for many many years not
because I did anything wrong not because
I somehow flouted the law but because
there was no process for me to actually
naturalize and so that is the case for
too many people for those those of us
who are immersed in the immigration
system we know too well that there are
deep fault lines in our system there are
deep gaps that need to be um that need
to be addressed and the fact is that
people are coming here in part because
they are looking for Safety and Security
and is our responsibility as a leader as
a global leader to create a system that
actually allows people to come here
legally but what we have is a system
that does not do that and instead
penalizes and punishes people for
Security may I just also refocus us on
this particular issue which is funding
for a program for which there is no
evidence it's needed and to ask the
legislature to just require if this
program is supportable that we should
use State taxpayer money for immigration
type um issues that it be supported by
evidence so that's what this is about
and not the larger discussion about
immigration policy and so well said
you all right thank you seeing no other
questions thank
you
me
Binet
thank you members of the committee I'm
here uh so my name is yel bisonet I'm
the legal director at the ACLU um of New
Hampshire and uh we are in support of
this bill because we think this program
is unsupported and unnecessary and I
think
my general message to this committee
today is regardless of where you stand
on immigration or the Border I would
just like you to think from a fiscal
perspective is this uh juice worth the
squeeze so to speak is this actually a
worthwhile use of what is a significant
amount of money $1.4 million may not
seem like that in the grand scheme of
things when you look at the overall
state budget but when you think about
what this state could do with $1.4
million whether it's funding teachers
whether it's funding Broadband whether
it's funding affordable housing I would
submit that there is so many better ways
to use this money and that's because I
don't think there is any data to support
that this is necessary and in fact I
think the data now shows that this is
completely unnecessary why do I say that
um ever since this program was put
forward um by by various um individuals
you know we've been trying to get data
right you know is this a New Hampshire
issue um because the data that we had
been given throughout is that you know
SWAT and sector there are issues there
are significant increases in
apprehensions and encounters within the
sector may be true but that SWAT and
sector is a big territory that doesn't
just include New Hampshire which is 58
miles but it in total spans over 250
miles so the bulk of that territory
excuse me actually principally includes
New York and Vermont so I think getting
granular here is actually like really
important you know are these
apprehensions occurring through channels
principally that exist in new uh New
York or Vermont or is this actually a
New Hampshire problem and we tried to
get that data we could not get that data
from the state because the state did not
have it even though they were advancing
a need for this proposal then we asked
border patrol you know all right you
have the data right can you you provided
because we want to know whether this is
a good use of resources because we're
all trying to be good stewards right of
our taxpayers money and border patrol
would not produce it um we filed the
lawsuit seeking that information where
we were asking for disaggregated M uh
apprehension data so you you're giving
us SWAT and sector data that's great but
we think it's important that it's broken
down so we can all figure out whether
this is really an issue here that's
worth worthwhile use of funds um I have
like breaking news for the committee
because I literally just got that data
this morning and um wanted to uh present
it to the committee um because we have
resolved that foyil lawsuit we had asked
that the data be produced by the end of
January um and uh they agreed to do that
and it was produced this morning and the
reason why I wanted it to be produced by
the end of this month is so we could
provide this information to this
committee so this committee could assess
independently for itself whether this is
a good investment or not so I want to
tell you what the data
says for um a 15-month
period And this is
between I'm sorry could we ask this day
to be provided in the original sorts yes
I I I actually plan on doing that I
haven't had an opportunity yet to write
it up for the committee uh we received
an email from uh Council uh for border
patrol and I'm going to convey that
directly to the committee with along
with some written testimony from the
ACLU uh hopefully by the end of
today um so the data that was received
is that from October 2022 to December
2023 uh there were uh 21 apprehensions
and encounters um th that 21 figure
actually principally uh concern 16 of
those 21 actually only implicated uh two
kind of separate incidents that occurred
Ur in January uh I'm sorry uh June and
September 2023 so we have 21
apprehensions for this 15 month window
let's break that down even further so
when this program was promulgated back
in early 2023 you know they were there
was um advocacy done to say this is
necessary because Swan and sector
increases have have been Monumental
during that time and that might be true
but during that same four-month time
frame there was only one apprehension in
New Hampshire so this was a New York
Vermont issue it was never a New
Hampshire issue based on the data that
has been produced also border patrol
advocated back in January 2023 that
there were
367 SWAT and sector apprehensions in
January 2023 which they which was
asserted by them to be a significant
increase again January there was only
one in New Hampshire which represents.
27% of the apprehension so I I just you
know want to be uh and also I would
submit to that from October 2022 to
December 22 there were also no
apprehensions in New Hampshire which was
another three-month window that was
being um uh ad asserted that there was a
significant increase uh in swat and
sector apprehension so I think all of
this really demonstrates that this is
not a New Hampshire issue um and and I
just think this is not a good use of
funds now that we have this particular
information so I I would really just ask
the committee to just evaluate whether
really this makes sense in light of this
data the the apprehensions that have
occurred those two incidents in 2023
those were done by border patrol not
local officials I think again is
evidence that border patrol is there I
think if folks who've traveled around
the North Country know that border
patrol is there um and that there isn't
really a need for this sub substantial
amount of funds I would also as well
with respect to stone garden that there
is already a federal funded program um
for uh increased law enforcement um in
the North Country um for when you look
at uh the state has received
$180,000 for fiscal year 2022 also
$200,000 for fiscal year uh
2023 uh I am also of the understanding
that for fiscal year
2022 of the
$180,000 um that was received $54,000
actually went unspent by the state
police so if they're not spending all
their money under that program I think
that does raise some concern as to
whether or not this separate program
using State taxpayer dollars is even
necessary so I think that concludes my
my testimony um and and I just think the
data doesn't support this and I would
ask that the committee um a vote odd to
pass on this
legislation okay thank you um one
question I have on your PIN card is you
checked off that you opposed the Bill oh
I I support it uh that is a mistake on
my part my apologies and thank you for
that
clarification I oppose the program I
support the
Bill thank you thank you though I
appreciate that all right I just made
that change card um questions yes
represent fellows yes could you just
explain to me you know what what the
definition of like an apprehension which
that one I think I kind of understand
yeah I you
know I think most of the data that we've
received probably are arrests or
apprehensions
um you know I I would have to kind of
look actually at the border of Patrol
definition of encounters I'm happy to
provide that to the committee uh if that
would be helpful to the extent that
there's a um there's you know a
distinction there um I don't have that
definition off the top of my head and I
apologize but I'll provide that to the
committee thank
you thank you represent Erie thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question thank you um one of the things
that has been obvious in the in the
public point or from public perception
sure and having visited the southern
border I've seen it in
detail um is that when there's a gap
someplace the Gap gets filled and used
as a point of entry illegal
entry um if
instead of a concerted effort across the
northern border where there has been
admittedly an increase in entries
including human trafficking including um
just plain immigration
issues would it not be reasonable to
perceive that if an area in Vermont in
New York is blocked off off and then the
area in Maine is blocked
off that the weak point would then
become the funnel and taking into
consideration the increase in human
trafficking and the fact that 93 is
considered to be a human traffi Corridor
and has been for a long time uh I
remember that from my testimony and or
from testimony by uh um both the uh uh
DEA and the border patrol when I was
sitting in uh criminal justice MH 20
years ago y would that not be
accurate I don't think it would be
reasonable and I just want to explain
why I don't all the border is not it's
not a one-sized fits-all all border
territory is not uh the same um and I
think when you look at the southern
border and you look at the northern
border there are probably I would submit
very good reasons in fact why the 58
miles of uh of New Hampshire Canadian
border are less trafficked and that's
because it is unlike certain portions of
the New York Vermont border incredibly
inhospitable for that those types of
Crossings I would submit that that is
probably one of the reasons why this is
less of a New Hampshire problem uh and
you know may be an issue for some of the
other states in the swan sector but it's
not necessarily an issue here I think
that's my response number one but also
and I think that's born out by the data
number two border patrol covers that
territory um and I don't think there's
any evidence to think that they you know
have um you know uh have failed in their
duties and in fact the apprehensions
that we have are apprehensions Again by
border patrol so uh to me this is all
just a numbers situation is there an
actual problem in New Hampshire and I
just don't see it I think there have
been a lot of assumptions made based on
other portions of the swaton sector but
there are real reasons to think that you
know this is different because portions
of the Border are different for various
reasons
yes represent
Bolton so I think the most compelling
thing that oh thank you Mr chair U the
most compelling thing that um I think
you indicated was 54,000 of the 180,000
of the stone garden funds were returned
and unspent and I'm just wondering if it
hits if those funds are pretty much uh
targeted the same enforcement or but the
funds that were looking at go through
State
Police that's a really great point right
because I think the program this is a
state program that I think is kind of
designed to do some of the same same
things right that that the federal stone
garden program has done the federal
stone garden program is a a grant making
program with federal funds this is a
state Grant making program I think a lot
of the recipients are going to be some
of the same police departments and I
think at least for fiscal year 2022 when
you had 30% of the funds unspent you
know why do we need more funds from the
state um State taxpayers that's my
perspective thank
you anybody else seeing none thank you
chairman next I have uh
Cardona thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee for hearing my testimony I'm
not an expert on the issue I just simply
come here as a resident of lonia New
Hampshire I also happen to serve on the
indigenous commission here for the State
of New Hampshire I do not have an
official statement from them as we
didn't have enough time to meet before
you guys were hearing this committee but
I think it's important to hear at least
from one indigenous person the take on
this the state is in dire need for other
programs to be fully funded especially
like public education where it actually
serves our communities and the fact that
we're sitting here on whether we want to
keep funding programs that don't need
the money at the northern border where
there is data that backs it up that
shows that there is not an issue here in
the state of New Hampshire where where
we're focusing on a problem if there is
any that should be federally um I
believe that there are many of you here
on this committee that are actually
really good people that do understand
this issue it's a humanitarian crisis
happening in this country not an illegal
immigration issue so I hope that um you
will put these funds towards the
programs that really desperately needed
in this state we have a housing crisis
in this state we have many issues I live
in lonia we have 400 homeless people in
our city and part of that was motivated
by the fact that Co and what happened to
the shelter program that got put in
lonia so let's focus on putting those
money towards those programs to solve
those issues in our community not on
further dividing our communities and I I
do want to say immigrants are not our
problem um I'm originally my family's
originally from many parts of the world
and I am very proud that I'm an American
that I have served my country I was in
americor for many years so I would hope
that this committee will continue to
talk about immigrants in a respectful
Manner and what they have contributed
whether they came from Ireland Italy
Mexico Brazil or whatever country you
came from or your families came from
thank
you question um no questions okay um I
have no more pin cards is there anyone
else who would like to testify on this
on this
Bill yes if not if not could I ask one
question to the sponsor quick
one um sure is there anyone else who
wants to testify on this
sure thank you president Murray on there
is no no 612 number for this program
okay which means it doesn't undergo the
regular fiveyear oversight that all the
other dedicated funds do and I wonder if
you would object to appending um putting
it in
612 um what would what difference would
that make with the legislation on it
only makes the difference that um it
will be recogn ized as a dedicated fund
of the State of New Hampshire and looked
at every 5 years by a committee that's
trying to see is is this overspending or
under spending what it's
got is the main criteria prefer the bill
in its form now but if that's the um
action the committee chooses to take I
would support that okay thanks represent
fellows um Mr chair I see there's
somebody from the state police here
I just I just wanted to ask a question
um this is RSA 21- p
colon7 and I'm wondering if we still
have 21
p68 um on the books it's crossb drug
interjection
interdiction program does does that
okay
yes your name
sir good morning I'm Brendan Davey I'm a
captain with the state police and uh
State Police takes no position on this
bill so strictly to answer your question
representative um it does appear that 21
p68 is still a law in effect and
followup do follow do you know if it it
it has a report do you know anything
about the budget the report or
anything I I know hate to spring it on
you like that
but
this is not um not an area of my uh
material focus and so I can't answer
that question for you ma'am it would it
would appear on the law that that is
still a requirement but um I've not been
involved in such a report can I just ask
that you send us that look up that
information send it to the committee
you okay is there anyone else would like
to testify on HB
1054 all right seeing none we'll close
hearing
un
are you ready for
okay okay the committee will come to
we will I will open the public hearing
on HB
1193 and um welcome representative Joe
Bill thank you Mr chairman and great to
see the members of the House Ways and
Means Committee again this morning uh
representative Joe Sweeny from
Rockingham 25 the town of Salem um I I
rarely uh think when I file istion or
when I have a an idea that I I would
consider it a great idea um however I
was validated when I filed this with OSS
that it was a great idea as a
representative rord from your committee
was concurrently filing very similar
legislation uh that then merged into
this bill uh for the child care tax
credit um now there were some uh issues
on my end and with OS in getting the
bill drafted as as we saw fit um and I
think you as the committee will be able
to work on it and there are some
suggested changes in the uh post fiscal
note about the bill and changes that can
be made uh to strengthen the bill and
make it a little bit stronger on the
policy points um to which I think
members of your committee are are in
tuned with need to be made uh but the
impotence behind this bill and
establishing a child care tax credit in
New Hampshire is very simple we're
obviously uh in an era where child care
expenses are making it harder for our
state to attract and retrain uh young
families uh to encourage young families
to stay in New Hampshire to have their
children in the state um and so we also
have a limited number of options from
the state level as to what we can do uh
in order to facilitate a better market
for child care facilities in the state
of New Hampshire we have a a special
committee on child care that's been
looking at recommendations over the last
year and I commend their efforts uh for
the State of New Hampshire in
identifying the small incremental ways
in which we can make things better and
this childcare tax credit has not been
discussed with with the child care
committee yet uh but I think it's a
small incremental way in which we can
make the child care situation in New
Hampshire a little bit better
essentially by targeting uh for
employers with eligible employees their
ability to write off from their state
business taxes incur child care expenses
up to a certain limit uh in order to
help retain their their young workers to
encourage those young workers to pursue
having a family uh with the cost of
child care not being a factor in them
not um not starting their family and
staying in the state of New Hampshire um
I think we can all agree that the the
best benefit the best social program is
a good job uh and that's not something
that the state can really get in the way
of of mandating certain benefits or
whatnot but this is just an opportunity
and incentive for existing employers to
begin offering uh assistance and in
child care expenses to their employees U
I'm happy to take questions on the bill
there are other experts uh on here uh
behind me I believe uh and obviously I
just really do want to give a shout out
to he's not testifying in the bill but
representative Rochford is the the real
impedence behind most of the real policy
in the bill mine was just the
overarching concept of of allowing
employers to write off child care
expenses okay great thank you questions
for representative Sweeny represent elme
thank you um I would not consider this
small on a tax credit removes money from
the jurisdiction of the finance
committee and um on can balloon into an
incredible amount of money or can end up
not being used by anybody and it is very
difficult to tell ahead um you have
capped the first part of this at $10
million a year our business profits tax
is showing signs of decreasing at this
point every other state is showing uh
showing Revenue decreases as the federal
stimulus ends um and your second part uh
the expenditures for maternity or
paternity leave have no has no cap
whatsoever and is and they are incapable
of estimating it in the fiscal
note so
um do you have you thought about what
this might doe to housing funding or
this might doe to to the funding that
goes on in the state budget on a routine
matter that um in Health and Human
Services or in other sectors that will
have to be cut if this does ballone so I
think based off I appreciate the
question I think based off of where the
current surpluses are lining up uh this
is not going to create a hole in the New
Hampshire budget a a $10 million cap in
the first instance
uh will just incentivize businesses and
employers to be able to retain their
employees which has a value into the
economy that we can't quantify with
state tax dollars and revenues uh the
second part about allowing uh employers
to expand uh if needed the maternity and
paternity leave that's currently offered
to their employees and then be able to
write off those additional expenses to
their tax cuts I think is just a smart
pro- family policy uh that we're lacking
in the state and that we can really move
the ball forward for young families and
our Employers in order to retain the
workforce that they need to be
successful so that our economy can
continue to grow without losing uh
knowledge and talent to other states
with with more reasonable uh and
Ames I'm wondering about the scope of
this bill and um this tax credit would
apply as I read it only to employees of
businesses that pay uh significant
enough um business profits tax to be
able to take and
use uh for the purposes described here
um this tax credit so that if I
understand this correctly and that's my
question to you um this leaves out of
this uh support for child care all the
employees of all the businesses that are
not uh able to take advantage of this
business profits tax tax
credit well I I so if I'm understanding
your your dilemma correctly it sounds as
if we're just not taxing small
businesses enough that they would be
able to write off their expenses no
there's not it no if if a business is
not large enough to produce the sorts of
revenues in which we're taxing them at a
rate in which writing off their child
care expenses that they're providing
makes sense to them then we're already
not taxing that we and there's another
bill that we can cut those business
taxes further if we want to release that
burden on those small businesses uh but
this bill is just providing a vehicle
for employers to provide child care
services and pay for those expenses to
their employees that are existing
there's no limitation in the bill for
how large or how small a taxpayer a
taxpaying entity has to be to apply for
this tax credit uh but the Dilemma
you're citing is just a sense of reality
that we have small businesses in the
state that aren't paying a high share of
taxes because we've cut taxes and we can
continue to provide Relief by cutting
taxes as well uh this this is simply one
piece in a in a long big puzzle to
provide relief to Granite Staters and to
make uh employers incentivized to
provide child care if they're able to do
so this isn't a mandate this is an
representative fellows and then
representative
ellerie do businesses get any kind of
federal um tax
credit or child care for that they
provide I I do not believe so just
follow up um some places might provide
child care on site would that that would
be just an expenditure for the business
correct and I think under this bill if
it's a if they're providing obviously
they would be providing a licensed child
care facility on site uh they would be
allowed to take those expenses and write
off it from their their bet or BPT but
not a tax credit no they could get a tax
credit for that expenditure if the
business is incurring an expense for the
Deliverance of child care through I'm
talking about Federal Federal Federal
I'm not aware of I'm saying in this bill
the proposal for the state is that they
would be able to write off those
incurred child care expenses from their
state taxes as a credit as opposed to it
as a tax credit yes as a OPP but so if
we didn't have tax credit they it they
can right now they can write it off as
an expenditure
correct from from their federal taxes
and it would lower their sure or stake
sorry from from the expenditure side of
things yes they could write it off as an
expenditure but this is specifically to
incentivize child care expenses going
forward thank
you um representative allary followed by
representative
um the the question that was asked by
representative Fells was regarding an
expenditure right now if an industry
let's take a huge one um with a couple
thousand employees offers
daycare um or Child Care on on campus
that's not a business
expense therefore that's just done out
of the largess of the the
business to attract employees and some
do offer that
currently however if this bill were to
pass then they could it take up to at
least
$100,000 for that expense so a smaller
company in New
Hampshire could offer
daycare and could cover the cost of one
or two
employees under that
$100,000 so do you see this bill is
benefiting the largest
employer collectively in the state that
is the small business benefiting more
than the large business and that's the
first question and a followup Mr chair
no I I appreciate the question and as
the bill pertains I think you're right I
think this benefits any business that
pursues the tax credit with an
individual cap of $100,000 and a total
program cap of $10 million it's going to
be a lot a lot of businesses filling up
that $10 million
cap and follow up yeah the followup on
that is where did this $10 million cap
come from does it is it going to be that
way does it need to be that high uh
what's the justification for that number
yeah the uh and I think uh that was part
of Representative roer's original draft
of it um I don't want to speak for him
on that provision but I think it's a
it's a good starting point for where we
can go with the program to see where the
need is and where the justification is
because right now obviously we don't
really have a good sense of of what the
need out there is one further followup
sure would there be
any positive effect to something of this
taking place If instead of uh a tax Gap
this could be um allowed as a business
expense uh for New Hampshire
taxation I wouldn't be opposed to that
strategy either and I think as as the
Ways and Means Committee you already
have to make changes to the bill based
on the department notes um and I think
that's a great for for your discussions
in executive session to
pursue thank you thank you Mr chair
thank you uh representative PL did you
have a question maybe there's a bit of a
question left after represent Val's
colloquy is there in a business expense
now that they could uh count as an
now any other
questions representative shamber thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
uh following up on represent of
's question about the 10 million going
back to line d page
112 uh shall not exceed 100,000 for any
tax taxpayer in a taxable year uh where
do that number come from that that is
just based off of ensuring that it's not
just large corporations in the state
taking the full $10 million cap so it's
kind of related to the $10 million cap
that you wouldn't want one employer to
take a significant amount of the of the
overall cap so limiting it to up to
$100,000 per taxpayer per
year so it's really just proportional to
the 10 million follow
up uh is there a priority list is
there items that a a company would have
to or business would have
to make other
than do they have to have a certain
number of employees or do they have to
have it's just an open an open open to
all
right seeing no more questions thank you
right thank
Barry thank you um my name is
representative Ross Barry I represent
Hillsboro 39 Manchester South End board
689 I'm the chair of the special
committee on childcare um we are tasked
with finding solutions to increase
access affordability and maintaining
quality childcare in state of New
Hampshire um so I'm here to kind of talk
about support for this bill maybe some
things that I think the committee should
take a look at um and um maybe some
propos changes so the first question I
would have about the bill I I love the
bill and concept let me start off with I
support the bill I support the bill and
concept um I want to kind of answer a
couple of questions to representative
aly's Point um we're talking about
people who qualify for the state
scholarship um so we're not talking
about every child going into child care
we're talking about the select few that
are on the state scholarship in my
Center that I own it's about one out of
every six children um those numbers
obviously will vary Center to Center um
Community to community um the way the
state scholarship works is the state
covers the state covers a portion of the
cost based on the survey that they do
every 3 years based on the median in the
median cost for that child's age group
um and then they have a little spread
they have a little grid that they use
based on the Family's income um and ju
opposed against federal poverty level
and the state produces a cost share um
value for the parents right so if you're
on the state scholarship you don't get
to go to child care centers for free I
don't believe anybody does I think some
I think they pay little like $5
sometimes um the more income they make
the more they have to pay um so you're
not talking about a like massive swath
of like covering $300 a week per child
across the board uh per employer you're
talking about what I I I assume this is
doing is I assume it's covering the cost
share part which is the parents part um
so you're talking about covering a much
smaller portion of the tuition um so
that would include their cost share and
then any overage that the child care
center charges higher than the state
median income uh the higher than the
state median price for the scholarship
so I what a exactly that fiscal impact
is I'm not sure um I would I would have
trouble envisioning a world in which it
got to $10 million um I wouldn't say
it's not possible um but I want once
again you're talking about people who
are currently
250% um poverty level and below and then
I assume you're talking about their cost
share which is an even smaller portion
of their actual tuition um so ways that
this might be beneficial obviously
you're dealing with workingclass people
at this income rate um you're talking
about relieving them you know anywhere
between $5 and up to like $120 a week um
off of somebody who's a 250% lower
federal poverty standard
um I wouldn't Envision like you know bae
or a company such as that which has high
salaries um taking advantage of this uh
I would Envision this being more used
for you know uh Dunkin Donuts workers or
other kind of entry-level workers um lot
of single mothers in those situations
um taking that cost share load off of
them um that's the part of it that I
wanted to speak to I'm happy to answer
any questions about it the one thing I
did want to point out is in the law in
the way it's written it says eligible um
so I I'm not aware of anybody who's
eligible who doesn't go on it um but in
theory you could have somebody who is
not eligible and not on it and then
obviously I I guess this would cover the
entire cause of the tuition um so I'll
try answer any questions I know that was
a lot um really quickly um but I'll try
to answer any questions I can thank you
representative PL yes it this is
introduced to our committee it's now our
bill to make amendments to Y but if you
have help on what amendments to make
that would be great yeah so the first
thing I would do is um on line 11 um I
would detach the um qualifications on
income level um I would just say if they
qualify for the scholarship the
scholarship does change um we just
expanded it uh in the last budget um so
that would give the the language more
flexibility going forward I would also
clarify that it goes to the cost share
um which is what I believe the intention
is um because otherwise you would be
effectively Subs like you might be
subsidizing the fund um which we did
hear testimony about how we wanted
businesses to take more of a larger role
um in the cost of childcare um so
there's something set for that but I
think the committee need makes makes to
make a decision um I believe the
intention is to cover the cost share um
but you could make an argument as to why
it should be first this and then the
scholarship uh which would make the
actual fund of the scholarship healthier
um and other opportunities for expansion
if that's the way the legislator wanted
to
go represent Aly thank you uh I'm
totally lost what I have never heard of
the State Child Care scholarship program
yep um so State schol the state
scholarship program is ferally funded um
and it it covers exactly kind of what
the uh the very last page in the
methodology um talk about it it's page
four um they talk about it it's the the
feds give us a certain amount of money
um in a partnership where the state
gives covers the tuition for um uh
lowincome families so we just made some
changes to the scholarship um the first
thing that got changed we used to have
an attendance base model um so basically
the state would only pay uh when the
child was present and the parent the
child had a certain number of limited
ABS absences uh providers reached out um
and said they wanted to move to an
attendance-based model which is what
Most states do um so now it's
attendance-based so that obviously
increased um the draw from that pool of
of funding um but that that that's money
that we get to basically Subs subsidize
low uh child care for lowincome families
um the fund I I've said this before in
committee and I believe there's only one
instance and representative wner could
probably correct me if I'm wrong because
she knows way more about this than I do
um I believe there's only one instance
in recent memory where the fund ran out
of money and then I believe at that
point they create a weit list so that's
something that I'm personally um very
cautious of but I don't believe that
this bill as written would impact that
uh the only I could see it impacting
that is if it put more people on to the
scholarship that currently qualify that
aren't on it but I'm not once again I
don't believe that's a large pool of
people um most child care centers um
like when when when we on board at our
Center we always ask do you qualify you
know here's all the paperwork um and you
can go do it because we take the state
scholarship most I would say the
overwhelming vast majority of childcare
centers uh take the state scholarship um
it's it's very simple the state always
pays right I don't have to go and track
down a pay from the state um but
basically what happens is at the end of
every week um Child Care Centers submit
their attendance logs um for the
individual children that are on the
scholarship uh they submit the amount
charged the state generates the uh
parents cost share and then what the
state's going to cover so what happens
is is you Bill the parent for the C
their cost share and the state sends you
the rest um and it's on a sliding income
scale um it's available online um but
it's you know it's it's federal poverty
level income scales so it's based on you
know number of people in the household
and how much money you make based on
gross
income could I follow up follow up um I
don't understand how this has to do with
um what I thought this bill was about
which is on child care provided by an
employer on site um I don't believe does
it say onsite for big
places because it says payments to a
child care provider yeah um
payments I don't I don't remember it
saying it on site yeah it may not it it
may not I I I if I'm wrong I don't
believe it remember saying it on site I
I um I don't believe the bill would be
written in such a way because there
aren't many employers that do that um I
know a question was raised about how
that would be yeah question be I mean
it's a very highly regulated industry I
me it's 100 over 100 pages of
regulations um I don't see a employer
jumping into that um unless they have to
it' be much easier just to do actually
kind of what I believe the intent of
this bill is which is to subsidize at a
um offsite
facility but through employers that on
use it to reduce their BP bet yeah I
mean look it's it's you know that's
that's kind of of your guys' world it's
not mine um you I am a business owner
obviously own a Childcare Center um you
know we you know I could say in my like
in my like I provide a grossly
discounted rate um for my teachers right
um and I have people that work for us
because they want you know close to free
childcare um so I think that there's a
there's a question of how that would be
handled um I'm not exactly sure how that
would be handled but I know that that's
a pretty common practice in the
childcare industry um but you know I
what I Envision this as is they are
they're basically covering they would be
covering to a certain extent the portion
that the state doesn't pay and taking
that off of the pral burden so once
again you're not talking about the whole
tuition in fact you're talking about um
a very low percentage of the tuition um
I think always less than
50% represent shamberg thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative taking
this question on line 10 it does mention
the New Hampshire Child Care scholarship
program how much money how much Federal
money does the state get for that
program uh I want to say it's 26.8
MJ yeah it's about I think the last
number I saw was 26.8 it's about 30
million thank you yeah state and federal
um but yeah it's
uh followup then followup first I
thought it was Federal now it is state
and federal how much so well it's mostly
it's mostly State like overwhelmingly
majorities I mean mostly Federal excuse
me mostly Federal I just want make sure
I'm getting this it's it's it's fed
money it's fed money that's sweet sweet
you representative do you have a
question no do you know the split no not
off the top of my head thank you sir
thank you any other questions but to my
to my that point this bill doesn't
really affect it right you're talking
about the portion that it doesn't cover
um so I not that not not not to dodge
the question I just tell you I know the
answer but I think the the questions
moot because you're not talking about
the actual scholarship you're talking
about the portion of tuition that the
scholarship doesn't cover which is which
is obviously not covered by the state or
parents yes thank you Mr chairman it
wouldn't it also make sense to um we're
talking about the New Hampshire Child
Care scholarship program and they're
getting help and it it's been my
experience uh as an employer
that you know that's that's great that
those people are getting help but it's
actually the people that are just above
that line that really need oh yeah
really need the help me I've given
raises and people come back to me and
said I wish I hadn't got the raise
because now I don't qualify for anything
so wouldn't it make sense to maybe even
increase the qualifications to to above
that line to to as a sliding scale to
help folks uh um get some relief yeah uh
so um I I'll let you guys answer the
money question on that cuz that's your
job as a policy position um the missing
Middle with child care is the group that
gets hit the hardest um and I've had
parents in tears when they've missed the
threshold by a couple hundred dollars um
because it's a significant drop off I
mean the the the fund does taper right
as you make more money the amount that
they pay does taper off but there is a
quite quite a cliff um and we are
working on other things to address that
um but there is no easy answer um child
care you know infant care in the state
of New Hampshire um cost about $15,000 a
year um because it operates on a teach a
4 to1 teacher ratio right um Child Care
Centers do not make any money on infant
care um they are lost leaders um or
break even leaders if you will inside
the business World um but yeah that
missing me that be a conversation you
guys as a committee have to have because
that would that would increase the cost
of this um or it could increase the cost
of this dramatically because obviously
now you're talking about an unfunded
part um from the from the Chalker
scholarship so now you are talking about
a full tuition bill um that would be
off so
elme yes do you think
that
on it would work
bureaucratically if um we're basing it
off the New Hampshire Child Care
scholarship program but when you get
above the level that that is your
turning to the employers that actually
make enough BP bet that they can uh
use use the the
offering so I I think the way that it
would probably work is uh the child care
center would probably Bill the employer
um I believe the payments are to be made
directly to the center um if that's I
believe that that's in there um that's
probably the way to do it childcare
centers especially dealing with the
state scholarship are already dealing
with a split billing situation right as
I said they're building the the state
for one side of it and the parent for
the other um and we do have to produce
tax documents for parents so that they
can do the um child care tax write off
um they were actually all due today so I
got a lot of inquiries about that from
my parents um but I don't think I don't
think it would be hard to produce that
number to an employer from a child care
side because it's just it's like billing
another parent right you have parents
you know children from split households
right I might build dad this side and
Mom this side and you know they have to
they each pay their separate portions um
I think that's how it would probably
work um in practice um every child care
center that accepts the state
scholarship has a state vendor ID
already so they're already kind of in
the bureaucratic system um you're not
really you know I'm definitely not for
burdening child care um centers with
more stuff in fact I've submitted a
suite of bills to undo some of the stuff
that we burden childcare centers with um
but I would imagine childcare centers
would would like this as another funding
source um that's probably more reliable
much I have a pink card for the Dr
Wang good morning members of the
committee my name is Lauren O Sullivan I
am the senior Financial Analyst at the
Department of
Revenue good morning I'm Keen Ming Wong
TX policy council with the
Dr the Department of Revenue does not
take a position on this bill so we are
just here today to um point out just
some of the items that we had pointed
out in the fiscal note um in need of to
either be addressed or some
clarification and we're also here to
answer any questions that you may
have so so let me begin um on on line 19
the term research and development
occurred is stated in the bill we
suggest amending that language to read
the qualified expenditures
paid we also suggest additional language
to be provided to clarify the types of
expenditures that qualify for the
maternity or paternity leave portion of
the
bill and we also suggest additional
language excuse me minute um is that in
the document you're sending around uh
yes
okay um this is a fiscal note quick
guide that we're passing around you may
have had it
emailed but this the okay okay
okay so that's what we're providing here
today yes can I just ask that you repeat
that slowly so we absorb your points one
time absolutely so um I'll I'll just
start again from the top so on line 19
of the bill um where the term research
and development occurred um that's the
language in there we suggest amending
that language to read qualified
expenditures
paid we also suggest additional language
be provided to clarify the types of
expenditures that qualify for the
maternity or paternity
leave and we also suggest additional
language in the proposed RSA
77-a colon
5 17 and RSA 77
e3f to clarify that the taxpayer may
choose to apply the child care um credit
against the BET BBT or a combination of
the both because it can be read that it
can um that it could be stacked um
that's one interpretation so just to
make that clear that if that is the
intent or not the intent of the
bill we also suggest additional
clarifying language added to section two
of the of the bill clarifying whether
the credit allowed is 50% of the
expenditures from maternity aternity
leave greater than the 12 weeks or if
it's the full expenditures of the
maternity paternity leave greater than
12 12 weeks because that the way it
reads it's like the
50% um under the uh Paid Family Leave
Act or the 12 weeks and we weren't sure
if that's at 50 or
100%
no um also um this based on the uh the
conversation that was uh had earlier on
with the previous uh
testimony uh I think a lot of the
discussion was on the qualification of
the um I guess the taxpayer or the
employee um if there is going to be any
changes to that uh I would say to be
honest um we're not very familiar with
the New Hampshire childcare credit uh
scholarship program um and if if
everything if the qualification of the
um the taxpayer or the um the employee
hes on that um
that item or that qualifying for that
that program I think we probably would
need more specific clarification as to
um the specific statute or specific
requirements that needs to be met um so
it's clearer to to the Dr when we
program and that point you just made
okay you don't find the
no uh we we had not focused on that
piece when we were when we were
preparing this fiscal no we were just
more focused on okay can we calculate
the numbers how does this really work um
yeah and also I think uh on the back of
the U at the back of the bill where
where the fiscal no is
attached where it mentions the um to be
eligible for the New Hampshire childcare
credit program Federal property
guidelines can exceed 250% that last
line there I believe that is added in by
the LBA I suspect as
much on on the uh the back of the bill
page the last page of the bill the last
line yeah I believe that that might have
LBA yeah representative PL I was perhaps
a bit too lazy and in my notes I said
please see fiscal note for other points
but you just made a point that's not in
the fiscal not
would you please repeat
it uh the point that I was making was
just to seek additional clarification if
um if based on the previous testimony
that the qualification for the
program hinges on specifically on the uh
qualification of the New
Hampshire Child Care scholarship program
uh and whether it is the um to cover the
cost sharing portion or not the cost
Shar sharing portion um so that that
that kind of clarification would be uh
program yes represent fellows thank you
um I asked a question earlier about a
business and under federal tax
law uh what can they do if they want to
offer offer like Child Care vouchers to
employees or if they wanted to have an
onsite Child Care
Facility can they claim that those
expenditures as um is are they just
expenditures of the company or does the
F and does the federal government have
any tax
care
unfortunately um the way the New
Hampshire business taxes calculations
start is from theal yeah so for I guess
the short answer is we we don't know
because the way we calculate the New
Hampshire business taxes is from line 28
of the federal return it's before any
return so you don't you're telling me
you don't know mhm yeah so essentially
um the starting point for the new to
calculate the New Hampshire side of the
taxes is 928 before credits so if
there's a federal Credit that's allowed
on the federal side um that would not
flow through to the New Hampshire return
unless there's some kind of specific
legislation that allows that follow up
and if it's if they can claim it as an
expenditure yep if it's claim as
expenditure it would be before line 28
and it would flow through to the New
Hampshire return and do and and do you
know if they can claim it as an
expenditure on the federal
side why not yeah if it's an if it's an
allowed deduction that's um by the
federal by by the Internal Revenue code
yeah it will be allowed in that sense
and then so the New Hampshire tax laws
piggy backs off well of the IRC of 2018
so if that's allowed on the federal side
we would then no that would flow through
and there would be no adjustment for
that deduction on the New Hampshire site
unless there's additional legislation on
the New Hampshire site that changes that
just one more followup so forget about
child tax credits are there other kinds
of
expenditures
that um the state of New Hampshire
allows get them to add in or to subtract
maybe so you're you're starting out with
that line 20 8 and then are there
certain kinds of expenditures
or credits that the federal government
didn't already take take that they're
allowed to deduct for the New Hampshire
business tax are you talking about just
Child Care related or just any any
credit oh yeah there's all sorts of
other there are there is a section in
the uh the BPT statute for additions and
deductions so there are additions and
deductions as well that's on top of
what's on the federal line
yep okay uh represent Alma you look like
you want to ask a question I'm just
trying to figure out how complex it
would be trying to put together
microphone trying to figure out how
complex it would be to put together New
Hampshire tax
law and a tax credit within that on with
program on as a basis starting as a
basis for it which is what we seem to be
doing because one is dealing with
families and each family is given a
different uh level of support depending
on how big it is and how poor it is and
on the other is
employees yeah I can see that that would
be complicated because um the way I
write the bill is um it is dependent on
the it ref it references the taxpayer
the taxpayer being the business
organization so the business organiz
ization would have paid certain
expenditure for uh the qualifying
expenditure for child care and then um
so in that sense to try to go back to
the uh the New Hampshire childcare
scholarship program using that as the
qualif qualifier uh I think we need to
fully understand um that program first
and then um how legislation wants to
determine that okay at which level the
uh the
expenditure would then meet the uh the
requirement where this credit would then
kick in I think that would be a
step-by-step approach there I I think
probably the first step is just to fully
understand the U the New Hampshire Child
Care scholarship program represent
spillsbury yes thank you Mr chairman as
so without making a prediction of how
soon or How likely it is that the total
uh credits claimed would aggregate to 10
million just not trying to assign um
levels of predictability but if that
occurred it would then require the Dr to
recalculate all the credits and impose a
prattle limitation back on each
individual taxpayer am I
correct yes that would be correct so it'
be I I think it looks something like the
the R&D credit um where there's a cap on
on the credit so we would have to wait
for all the applications for any
particular tax year to come in and then
to see if it exceeds the the $10 million
or not um and then do the necessary
pratic calculation yeah thank
you all right seeing Oh represent
Eller thank you for taking my
questions the um you went you just
indicated that this appears to be a kind
of of a um a difficult or a
administrative um complexity in meshing
the child credit program with the
federal program with this particular U
tax
credit in your estimation from Dr stand
would it be more
simpler is it more simpler simp would it
be simpler to to just
deduction for the provision of to a cap
of to an aggregate
of um type
legislation and then combine that with
uh piggyback that on top of whatever if
the federal government allows a business
deduction would that make it easier for
Dr to administer the bill there we go I
got the
question um just to to to backtrack on
what I mentioned earlier first off I
think we just need to uh in terms of the
complexity it's just to first off we
need need to understand the the workings
of the uh the New Hampshire Child Care
scholarship program and essentially what
are their qualifications and and and the
thresholds um and then then then applied
this legislation as to how it would then
carry out but then to answer your
question um definitely yes if if it's
just a straight up uh allowing an
expenses deduction on the New Hampshire
tax returns um without considering any
other um qualifications to be met
so unless other than uh the the taxpayer
or the business organization having paid
the expense uh directly to the child
care provider like like what it stated
in in the bill um and then or maybe up
to a certain amount uh of uh cap on the
expense allowed um yeah that I think
that would be more straightforward for
sure
yeah thank you I'm thinking um at this
point maybe we should um given there's
some question about the child care uh
scholarship program and how that
connects I'm wondering if we should
defer any further questions uh to a work
session and have you back at that at
that time
HHS
much okay was there anyone else that
wanted to testify on HP
seeing none we'll close the public
1193 and we'll open the public hearing
sponsor okay wow I'll invite the sponsor
up representative Wilhelm and if you'd
later thank you chairman and uh good
afternoon officially um for the record
my name is represented Matt Wilhelm I
represent Hillsboro District 40 which
covers Manchester WS 13 10 11 and 12 uh
this bill is pretty
straightforward uh it establishes a
three member study committee one Senator
and two Representatives uh to study the
feasibility and impact of a lowincome
housing tax credit uh and file a report
year first question what is a low-income
housing tax credit uh this is a concept
that has been successfully implemented
at the federal level uh and in more than
half of the states with the goal of
generating private investment in
affordable
housing the way it works and some
aspects uh vary you know based on how
each state implements it uh is that
developers are provided a credit on
taxes owed for investments in affordable
housing the federal government has a
low-income housing tax credit program uh
which was established in 1986 under the
Reagan
Administration uh under the federal
program developers are offered
non-refundable and transferable tax
credits to subsidize the construction
and Rehabilitation of housing
developments that have strict income
limits for eligible tenants and their
cost of
housing since it was created the Federal
program has subsidized over
47,500 projects and 3.13 million housing
units uses an average of uh $8 billion
in forone revenue forone revenue excuse
me uh to subsidize the costs of building
more than 107,000 units across
1,411 projects each
year 28 other states have implemented
some version of their own low-income
housing tax credit program including
every other state in New England the
programs vary widely with respect to
duration of the tax credit term and the
share of the contribution against which
the credits may be claimed the eligible
activities and affordability
requirements uh and other program
features which is very much why uh
calling for a study in this bill there's
so many different ways that you can go
about uh structuring the program some
states separate their tax credit program
from the federal uh low-income housing
tax credit program While others
piggyback on the federal tax credit and
automatically award State credits to
investors in the federal program uh to
help fill gaps in development
costs uh I don't have to tell all of you
but here in New Hampshire uh we
desperately need more housing especially
affordable housing uh to ensure that our
businesses have the workers that they
need and seniors have a place to
downsize and young people can afford to
move to our state it can be challenging
for developers to make the financial
math uh work for Workforce housing and
affordable housing options uh this is
true for for-profit nonprofit and
housing authorities developers utilize
Iz Capital Stacks that line up all the
various funding sources to make a
project
work and there are limited state level
Financial tools available for affordable
housing at a time when we desperately
need it um you know we have the
affordable housing fund we have invest
NH uh these are programs that support
affordable housing um but this is
intentionally a broader program the
study would determine how the tax credit
is implemented including which agency or
organization would award an admin Min it
um and you know as I was sitting and
listening to the the previous Bill uh
which prescribes a new tax credit
program uh House Bill 1470 would create
space to study the issue over the summer
uh and fall and allow for a vetted
proposal to be ready for the legislature
to consider uh as part of next year's
budget cycle so I you know I would
encourage you uh you know consider the
bill uh but also oo uh want to encourage
you to consider an
amendment uh to expand the duties to
consider other tax incentives to
increase the production and
affordability of housing uh and
encourage the study committee to
recommend proposed legislation for the
2025 session I've got a uh a draft of of
that proposed amendment just makes a
minor tweak to um number three duties uh
and I'll pass that around but you know
this is really an opportunity for
businesses to reduce uh their New
Hampshire tax burden by investing in
desperately needed affordable housing
options it's a real win-win uh for
housing and for our businesses so happy
to take questions but also recognize
that uh we've got some real housing
experts behind us okay representative PL
yes thank you I saw that you were
reading from prepared notes would you
mind submitting them absolutely you were
speaking five times fast so than I could
type you bet okay thank you thank you
representative representative fellows um
yes I'm just wondering if we could see
that Amendment um before we let you get
out of your chair absolutely you didn't
get out of the chair to hand that around
I'm gonna do that real quick because one
of my um concerns is the scope of it and
and just from the basic bill it doesn't
well the
notes in the notes I don't have copies
for everybody representative but I'll
I'll make sure you get them uh
representative Aly followed by
representative
Ro yes on do you have something that
explains or is someone else going to
provide something that
explains uh the federal
program we can get you more information
on that and why
only two
people well that is certainly I'll
answer the second part of the question
first um that is certainly up to your
committee to decide uh what is in the
the final package that we vote on on the
floor so if you want to expand it um
please feel free um just a jumping off
point uh as for the federal liac or the
low-income housing tax credit program um
I think some of the issue experts may be
able to share more about that um but we
can also get you some additional
information representative Al me
uh representative Wilhelm does your
Amendment uh fully replace the current
bill uh I think in bold I don't now have
a copy of it but I think in bold was the
addition I see okay
yeah uh did you have a followup or
roord okay it must be a separate
question okay all right thank you Mr
chairman so I
I understand where you're getting
getting at and um we you know the with
the just to talk about the low-income
housing I mean that certainly is an
issue but also what I'm hearing a lot of
is Workforce housing I mean it's not
necessarily low income but there are
people that have jobs they are making
money they they still can't um they
still can't find housing would you be
willing to expand this to look at that
those those Solutions as well thanks for
the question representative uh certainly
open to that um but do want to put the
federal program front and center because
I think depending on how a program is
structured it may need to fit into the
federal guidelines for low income
housing um but certainly open to you
know other possibilities uh to to
address Workforce
housing representative
erery thank you representative for
taking my
question this may come off to hars but
it's not meant that way um because this
is an issue it's an an important issue
you want to have this report done by
the put with any adjective in there you
want to is this going to get done in
that short period of time when we don't
meet in August it's an election year
that leaves October and November well it
leaves October because November you got
the election then after
that people are going to care or they're
not going to care here depending upon
what happened in their own
individual um election cycle in addition
you have three
people and yet you're you're going to be
bringing in information with all the
additions and everything else from uh it
would seem that you would need someone
from fiscal or Finance you would need
someone from Health and Human Services
um committees to be involved you need
somebody from ways and means to be
involved as to the effect on on on it
seems to me that however
well-intentioned this is it doesn't seem
to meet a um committee
qualification maybe a commission
qualification with a multi-year task of
it maybe more appropriate but it seems
it's not going to accomplish its goal
unless there's a preconceived answer and
that's you know
that's conspiracy theory talking but um
and we both know
what so my question
is even though this is well intentioned
even though it addresses a topic is this
bill
needed I think it's a great question
thank you for it uh I think the timeline
is ambitious but achievable I think you
know to representative aly's Point um
perhaps it needs to be a larger uh
Committee of of Representatives and
Senators that are uh rolling up their
sleeves and dealing with it I mean
question is is it needed I would argue
yes and is it uh you know sh should we
put it aside and say we're not going to
start working on a plan uh or consider
what might be possible uh versus
actually getting started uh I would I
would say let's get started no matter
how big the task is repres shamber just
a comment on representative olry you
made the correct Point representative
willham that it's 45 days after passage
of this that it would start they don't
have to wait till August September they
can start in 1 of April if it's passed
by the
house well it has to get passed by the
house over to the Senate passed by the
Senate signed by the government Governor
if people want to work it'll get
done okay represent fellows um yes I'm
wondering if you can Define what you
mean by low what does it say low income
low income housing um is I in in my mind
that means subsidized housing so is that
what you're talking about so I'm going
to let the issue experts behind me
address that one and also know that we
need to get you some additional
information on the federal program which
I think will help to clarify okay
you next I have uh Ben
housing
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
committee members I'm Ben Frost I'm the
deputy executive director and chief
legal officer for New Hampshire housing
we are the state's Housing Finance
Agency and we are also the state's uh
allocator of the federal low-income
housing tax credit so I'm happy to
address any program specific questions
uh regarding that program um as
representative Wilhelm indicated uh the
the federal tax credit has been around
for a long time as part of the corporate
tax tax reform in 1986 made part of the
permanent tax code in the early 9s and
is the uh the Nations New Hampshire's
included uh number one driver of uh the
development of affordable housing uh it
it is the thing that makes this stuff
happen um and as representative wilham
pointed out a number of other states I
think he said 28 uh already have a state
uh low-income housing tax credit another
five are actively considering adoption
of low-income housing tax credit uh this
is not a a new idea it's a proven idea
something that works and has worked for
decades
um that the tax credit the federal tax
credit and this is not to say that this
is how New Hampshire's tax credit would
work if if it were adopted by the
legislature but the federal tax credit
effectively is a public private
partnership so on the state level uh a
state agent and here in New Hampshire
housing uh is the allocator and we put
out um a essentially a call for
proposals this is a competitive process
developers present to us their proposals
for development which have to be very
welldeveloped uh that that that is they
have to have their local permits in line
they have to be ready to go pretty much
but for the financing of the project uh
that's the the one thing that's holding
them back uh if they are successful if
they meet threshold standards and then
uh uh are competitive and get an award
an allocation of a uh a tax credit they
then the developer then has to go out
and sell that tax credit to
investors uh the investors um bid on
this in an open market and this is often
done through syndicators um but there
there is a market for these tax credits
which is very robust uh it's not quite
as strong as it was uh since the more
recent uh corporate tax reform but it is
still very strong uh and uh as a result
of the the investors involvement the
investors essentially pay for those tax
credits they become investors in the
projects and in exchange get a a
write-off against their Federal
corporate income tax
liability uh the developers then take
that development equity and build the
project uh the the investor gets under
the federal law gets a A 10e year uh
right off against uh whatever it
purchased in in the market for its uh
tax credit uh 10 years they're on the
hook for 15 years uh so there is really
strong um investor oversight of these
projects so what we call Private Market
discipline uh in these these low-income
housing uh rental projects uh it's
something that works and works really
well
um representative Aly I I I hope that
addresses in part the question you asked
about how the the program works as
representative wilhem indicated we'd be
happy to get you a lot more information
and we can make it concise we can make
it voluminous uh we'll start with
concise and if you want voluminous we
can give you that too it is arguably the
most complex portion of the federal tax
code um I've been told that um I don't
delve into it myself um I leave that to
others uh to do um uh representative Ro
for you you asked about the difference
between um uh Workforce housing and
low-income housing the and this actually
gets to representative fellow's question
about what does low-income mean under
federal law for the federal tax credit
program uh low income means uh
households earning up to 60% of the area
Medan income and the areas are very
throughout the state and the those
income levels also vary those are uh
defined annually by Hud
although the federal program is not a
HUD program it is a treasury program
it's a tax credit
program um a lot of the people a lot of
the households occupying these projects
are in fact in the workforce uh roughly
2third of the households the the
residents of low-income housing tax
credit projects in New Hampshire are
either elderly or disabled the remainder
are in the workforce they are people who
who are making uh incomes that are low
they qualified to to reside there um uh
but yes I'd say this as a study
committee uh why not open it up to that
that uh broader
inquiry um as far as whether it's a
committee or a commission uh as as
introduced it's a committee um it it's
immaterial to us uh we are happy to work
with this committee and then uh if the
legislature forms the study committee
with that study committee uh to achieve
the results in the time uh indicated uh
it's it's the kind of work that we uh do
I would be happy to take any questions
um and just note that we also support
the amendment uh proferred by
representative will Holm thank you
representative elme thank you just a
quick question and maybe I was just
writing too hard to hear you uh they're
on the investors are on the hook for 15
years for what uh they are liable uh for
to the federal government for the
project being built for not not the
project being built because the tax
credit doesn't kick in until the project
is
occupied um but for
compliance with uh Federal standards and
with um our standards at New Hampshire
housing as the tax credit allocator so
conceivably and this this rarely happens
but it does happen uh investment may get
recaptured and the investor has to
essentially pay back their investment uh
to the federal government uh it's a big
stick uh and as a result the investors
watch very carefully over these projects
uh for
compliance representative
fellows so I I think my question is
related to that so I I wanted
to I have several little questions
question s are are these always
rentals these are always rentals okay so
is one of the things that they the
compliance for the 15 years is that one
of those things making sure that they
the rent doesn't go up does it it has to
stay at that 60%
level is yes that that is correct
representative and one more piece so so
if I buy a $100,000
of these credits I give the developer
$100,000 and I get
credits how do I take advantage of that
I get to deduct $10,000 a year for 10
years
or the this is a little more complex
question um the the answer is that uh
new and I'll use New Hampshire as an
example because that's what I'm familiar
with uh we current are are our
2024 allocation is a little over $4
million that because of the um the
10-year uh period you multiply by 10 but
then you also apply the the market
Factor these tax credits tend to sell
for something like 90 to 95 cents on the
dollar so the $4 million annually will
yield something on the order of $35 to
$40 million in development equity
a project might get an allocation of
$800,000 of tax credits which is then
marketed to produce several million
dollars of development Equity from the
developer um the the developer then uses
that Equity to build the project now I
question i' be happy to T talk with you
offline as well okay um any other
questions
questions yes thank you I just as uh
would you agree I just checked with the
world population data that which markets
the uh 2024 meeting incoming New
884 and 80% of that is 70
71 roughly so would you agree that maybe
1,000 uh gross is the uh low income
level for tax
credits uh representative that number is
actually high that the because the uh
calculation is 60% not 80% excuse me and
it also varies by area within the state
so um and and one thing we haven't
talked about is the the complexity of of
the financing of these projects the tax
credit is one piece uh there are often
times many other layers of financing
which may themselves have other far
greater restrictions for example the
National Housing Trust Fund New
Hampshire housing receives uh New
Hampshire receives we allocate uh three3
to4 million a year it's a block grant
and that is for use with extremely
low-income housing uh households that
are earning up to 30% of the area median
income so a development that's using a
the National Housing Trust Fund in
addition to the low-income housing tax
credit would be limited to that 30%
level follow up Mr chair follow up uh
thank you for that if you could you you
were talking about an area uh income
which is isn't going to show up um on
that could you provide that uh to the
committee and I what also like to thank
you for
illustrating the complexity of this uh
representative all set oh question yes
represent so I'm wondering do you make
projections about how many of these
units are needed because there you know
there is demographic data from the
Census tell tells us how many people
will fall in different income categories
and not not all of them are going to use
this program that some of them might
live with relatives or whatever so where
where where does this go because we've
got a aging population that's going to
they're not going to have regular
incomes they're going to have just so
Social Security and maybe a little bit
out I'm just wondering if we're just
going to need more and more and more and
more of these
rentals representative that is that's an
excellent question and for as a as a
starting point I would refer you to a
study that New Hampshire housing
completed in 2023 it's the Statewide
housing needs assessment which indicates
that we have a current shortage of over
23,000 units of housing of all types for
all
incomes uh based on projected population
growth we will need a total of 60,000
produced by 2030 a total of 990,000
units produced by 2040 that see those
seems like very big numbers but it
actually amounts to something on the
order of a 35% increase in housing
production so that that is doable uh
it's a big lift but it is doable uh but
that's that's for all income types uh
that study does break things down I
don't have the numbers off the top of my
head that indicate what what we need for
certain income levels but uh the need is
significant
so all right just follow so I I um thank
you for sending that report to me about
a month or so ago I will look for that
section thank
you all right um I still have more pin
cards
Evans
thank you chairman uh committee members
thank you for the opportunity to testify
in support of HB 1470 for the record my
name is Kristen Evans and I am the
director of policy and advocacy for AEL
New Hampshire AEL is a disability
Justice organization and we are
nonpartisan nonprofit that fights for
the civil and human rights of children
and adults with disabilities as an
organization committed to disability
Justice we would like to express our
strong support for this Bill we believe
that this bill represents a crucial step
towards addressing the housing
challenges faced by individuals with
disabilities in our community according
to the National Council on disability
people with disabilities are
significantly more likely to experience
housing instability and homelessness
compared to the general population
Additionally the shortage of accessible
and affordable housing options further
exaggerates these challenges in New
Hampshire alone there's a shortage of
over 14,000 affordable and accessible
rentals rental homes for individuals
with disabilities as reported by the
national low-income housing Coalition
the implementation of a low-income
housing tax credit has proven to Be an
Effective tool in increasing the
availability of affordable housing
across the country states such as
California Massachusetts and Oregon have
successfully utilized low income tax
credits to incentivized private
developers to build or rehabilitate
affordable housing units these
initiatives have not only provided safe
and stable housing for low-income
individuals and families but have also
contributed to economic growth and
community
development HB 1470 demonstrates a
commitment to addressing the housing
needs of individuals with disabilities
and other marginalized communities
through comprehensive research and
Analysis this committee can identify
innovative solutions to increase the
availability of affordable and
accessible housing options thereby
improving the quality of life for
thousands of individuals with
disabilities in our state in conclusion
we urge you to support hb1 1470
investing in affordable housing is not
only a matter of social justice but also
a sound economic decision that benefits
our entire Community together we can
work towards creating a more inclusive
and equit Equitable Society where
everyone has access to Safe affordable
and accessible housing thank you for
your time representative flut would you
mind submitting those notes you read
yeah okay um any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
next is um or the last pin card I have
right now is
Alyssa Mar margolin if I'm saying that
properly or
not Ellis yes members of the committee
good afternoon for the record my name is
Alyssa margolin I serve as director of
housing action New Hampshire where
Statewide Coalition of 80 organizations
United in support of improving state and
federal policy so everyone in New
Hampshire has a place to call home our
members are those who finance develop
manage affordable housing properties uh
low-income family advocates homeless
service agencies and public housing
agencies um we're in support of this
bill and thank you for your serious
consideration um as Mr Frost mentioned
the housing credit and I I do want to
note one of the great points that Mr
Frost made was that the what we are
members call the capital stack depending
on what financing that they receive
really depends on who lives there and
what income bracket they find themselves
in so um another reason for considering
that amendment is to consider the issue
around Workforce housing um because um
you can be building for uh people who
are primarily in the workforce or people
who are uh primarily extremely low
income um and uh you know depending on
on the fining ing tools is might be
worth a study committee looking at how
you want to Fashion a New Hampshire
proposal another interesting
um uh tidbit is that right now as uh
Congress is putting together the the new
tax package the uh housing credit
Improvement act has some uh enhancements
to this very popular program known as
the low-income housing tax credit and
because of the complexities that Mr
Frost talked about they're going to
rename the program the housing credit
instead of the low-income housing credit
because it really raises a lot of
questions and it's not super accurate
all the time sometimes it really is very
low income extremely low income and
sometimes it is uh Workforce um
depending on on the project so I will
say our members this is the number one
um program financing tool um in New
Hampshire that creates the production of
affordable housing stock it is extremely
competitive for tax credits and it is
extremely uh uh uh attractive to
investors and has been critical uh to
making any progress as you know the
housing crisis is very severe it we have
three polls recent polls uh from St
anome UNH Emerson College that all say
that the housing crisis is the number
one issue for New Hampshire residents
right now um and uh Mr Frost shared the
sobering uh data points um about how
many many units are are needed so um you
know we as we start to do the work that
needs to be done um before the upcoming
budget we welcome the opportunity for
legislators or a larger commission to
come together to explore um what a
credit would look like in New Hampshire
and um and and how it would work so urge
your support for this I'm happy to take
any questions thank you representative
elme thank you um
today and uh in recent weeks on we have
been told to cut our taxes
considerably on your asking for more
revenue for what is one of our biggest
needs according to the Bia and a lot of
other people on another one is child
care and there was someone in here for
that just before uh how how do we
reconcile these things thank you I mean
don't come to the ones that are trying
to cut the revenue that could be
used um well I'm here to speak on behalf
of the the housing needs and the um you
know and our members who are on the
front lines of uh trying to serve those
in their communities and the you know
essentially an unserved Market there is
a demand for housing that's more
affordable and um without these
financing tools if you just you know
they they become unaffordable right now
to to to people of of you know of a lot
of incomes I mean what I how I describe
it is I one of the reasons I think that
the political will has increased around
this issue is just because you know the
um the recognition in the general public
that housing is the crisis is so acute
and that's because it's impacting
everyone at this point even if you're
comfortable in your home at the price
point that you're paying it's likely
impacting your children or your
neighbors or your community and it's
certainly if you're trying to grow your
Workforce it's probably the number one
impediment to you growing your business
um so that is I we need an all Hands-On
deck approach if we're really going to
make that achievable goal of increasing
housing production right and so we need
all the tools so I to answer your
question more directly representative
Aly I would say you know budgets are
always about choices and priorities and
and and different needs and and we know
that there are many competing needs in
the state and we ask you know we do the
the homework necessary to to look at the
tools to to address the housing needs
Ames uh thank you I I really appreciate
uh and understand that the depth and
extent of this Pro problem that you're
trying to address is huge and important
um I'm wondering if uh you've seen I
should have asked Mr Frost this question
um as well any reports that
quantify how much might be diverted
essentially from the business taxes
because that's what we're talking about
to make a splash to to affect this uh or
to to do something if there been any
concrete studies on well if we have less
and so tax credit we'd get thus and so
reward right I mean you you in order to
have a market for tax credit you need a
a tax burden that you're trying to avoid
but I I am not aware of any of those
studies and um I don't know if Mr Frost
is nope shaking his head now for the
record but um certainly another
important point for a committee or
something we would need to understand um
if we were going to come in with a
proposal included into in the budget
following
year
followup I guess related to that and
this reflects my lack of understanding
on this issue um those other states that
have adopted state level tax credits do
they engage their individual income tax
as well as their business tax corporate
tax um
in whatever uh tax credit product that
they work out do you know I don't
know I don't know my my my sense is that
it would vary but it would likely be
more on the corporate Tex side um but uh
you know it's certainly something worth
looking into okay thank
you representative ORS thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question so
does any of this provide an Avenue to
get some of the people living on the
streets off the streets and into some of
this housing we're talking about or
you're referring to so um the concerning
issue of the increase in homelessness um
I think is uh directly connected to the
housing shortage I think I mentioned we
were feeling like we were all impacted
uh earlier by the housing crisis and
talked about the impediments to
Workforce Development now consider
yourself maybe more financially fragile
say you're a single parent in a low-wage
job with a couple of kids and you
experience um a Health crisis or or
something I mean you could see the
vulnerability in a in a market um with a
05 vacancy rate and a required hourly
wage of close to $30 an hour in New
Hampshire so um the um so yes I I do
think it's connected but it kind of
depends on the units that you develop
and um and and what our members like to
say is they prefer not
to have prescriptive financing tools
that require developers to build for
certain populations because they prefer
the flexibility of responding to local
needs
um there is a desire sometimes to say we
should only build you know this type of
housing uh for people in recovery or
this for people um fleeing you know
domestic violence um and in some cases
that that might be the right solution
but we prefer flexible financing tools
so we can respond locally and we do have
examples in New Hampshire of
successfully building for chronically
homeless and providing ongoing
supportive services within that context
um and uh something that we need to
proliferate for sure uh when we start
talking about how to serve our more
vulnerable populations with such a basic
need so thank you for the question great
representative uh roachford yes thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so we've got where I come from
there are a number of builders that have
either started projects and stopped them
or decided not to start housing project
despite the need um because of the
inflation and the cost of materials uh
and you know even and then you add in
the cost of the cost of money is is very
expensive right now as well the finance
it I I like the idea this is you know
and I think tax incentives are a
wonderful way to do this but would are
you do you think this is enough uh if we
were to give a tax
credit um in in other in in the amended
proposed amendments as other kind of
opens the the other ways to tax credit
is that enough to
offset the increases in uh interest
rates and building materials in order to
maybe start some of these projects back
up candidly you know probably not it's
not enough but it will make a difference
for those developers who are attracted
to this type of favorable financing um
but we're hearing the same thing from
our members uh inflation impacting you
know labor costs um materials costs uh
you know supply side challenges that
continue um and makes it harder uh to
build affordably and the need for more
subsidy in a in a project so uh
essentially asking for more tools not
less or not fewer tools and um but
ultimately we're going to need the
market to build and as well as um you
know affordable housing financed uh
we're gonna but we need the both the
private Market to respond and uh and do
what we can to make sure that we're
we're building um affordable housing as
well okay thank you very much thank
you is there anyone else who would like
to testify on hb1
1470 okay seeing none I'll close the
public
hearing
yeah I'll open the public hearing on hb1
1613 and
um welcome up the uh sponsor
Muse
thank you members of the committee uh my
name is representative David Muse uh I
represent Portsmouth Newington and
Newcastle um I'm before you today uh in
large part because of a news story uh
that I read in 2023 in the New Hampshire
bulletin and the subject of that story
was a settlement that the state of New
Hampshire uh received from Monsanto uh
for $25 million for PCB contamination
across the state uh pcbs if you're not
familiar with them are polychoral bif
phenols they were outlawed uh by the
federal government in
1979 uh they were used in applications
like um uh oil that was used uh in
Transformers uh uh that would actually
cool the Transformers while they were
working uh to provide us with uh with
electricity uh they were also used in
other industrial applications when they
were outlawed in 1979 there was rush to
uh dispose of a lot of this waste oil
and a lot of this waste PCB material um
some of it found its way into trucks uh
in New Hampshire that were used uh to uh
oil dirt roads in the summertime uh when
the dust uh is known to choke the air um
some of that oil was also illegally
disposed of uh uh sometimes on land
sometimes in
waterways uh and uh other PCB uh uh uh
components were uh were also uh
improperly disposed of uh in that period
um like the past chemicals I think that
a lot of us have become familiar with
over the last few years um pcbs are
bioaccumulative um uh they also take a
long time to break down in the
environment hundreds of years uh so some
of the health impacts uh that can be
caused as a result of PCB contamination
are things uh like cancer liver problems
uh and birth defs uh there's a reason
1979 uh according to the story in the
New Hampshire bulletin um uh pcbs have
actually impaired 104 uh water bodies uh
in New Hampshire at least
63,000 Acres of surface water and at
least uh 2.3 linear miles of the sogan
river um contaminated Lon eggs have been
identified in 20 Lakes uh with the
highest levels of pcbs being in Squam
Lake uh so we're not talking about
things that are something that's just a
problem around major cities this is a
problem in our recreational areas as
well uh so the good news part of this
story is that in 2022 the state of New
Hampshire received a $25 million
settlement from monsano corporation
which was one of the main manufacturers
of
pcbs um the bad news uh is that uh the
lawyers got $5 million of that
settlement and the remaining $20 million
of that settlement went into the general
fund so why you may ask did that
settlement go into the general fund
instead of getting used to remediate PCB
contamination uh to monitor it to
educate people about it to actually do
something about the contamination that
the settlement was received for uh and
the answer to that question is we
actually
uh had no law in place that would have
specifically directed uh that money from
that type of settlement into a specific
environmental Fund in New Hampshire so
so for example we actually have a law in
New Hampshire that directs things like
pasas settlements into the drinking and
groundwater trust fund um uh we had
nothing like that set up uh other funds
that are comparable to that we have the
opioid trust fund uh which is not an
environment Al trust fund but we do have
the mbte trust fund so in the absence of
having a place that the
legislature uh uh essentially directed
the money to U the Attorney General is
allowed to release those funds into the
general fund so once they're releasing
in the general fund sometimes money like
that can be used to remediate
environmental contamination but it also
can be used to pay for things like copy
your paper and toner and gas for snow
plows and things of that of that nature
once it goes in there we really don't
know what's happening to it so in
response to putting it into the general
fund one of the things that the governor
recommended was a $6 million allocation
uh to actually address PCB contamination
that the legislature decided not to act
on so so in essence we received $20
million for a PCB settlement and we
actually may have used none of it to
remediate or monitor PCP container
mination on our state which according to
the New Hampshire bulletin story remains
a significant problem in this state so
what what this bill does is it attempts
to address this situation going forward
um what it would do is it would create a
so a Soil and Water contamination trust
fund and any funds received for an
environmental uh settlement
contamination settlement where the
disposition of money hasn't been
previously directed by the legislature
would actually be deposit ited into this
fund by the Attorney General until the
legislature can direct what the
legislature wants to do with these funds
you know it's it's it's a pretty simple
idea um money that we receive for
environmental contamination should
actually be used to combat environmental
contamination um so I think we have a a
glitch in our law that right now allows
it to be used for uh for other purposes
I think what I'm trying to do
uh is address this glitch and I would be
the first to admit to you it's this is
the first time I've tried to draft
legislation of this kind and we are
going to hear from folks in the
Department of Health and Human Services
who have some ideas about how
potentially uh the bill could be uh uh
made more specific in a way that would
be helpful and uh I would urge you to
listen to whatever they suggest Pretty
strongly uh because we have we have an
issue with contamination in this state
um p contamination alone uh if if we
look at the new EPA uh standards that
have just come down if we try to REM
remediate all of the the just the pasas
contamination uh that that we've already
identified in New Hampshire the cost is
going to run into several billion
dollars there are things out there um
that we haven't accounted for um there
are things that out there that we may
not even know about yet there are
settlements this settlement is an
example of a settlement um where I don't
think people in the legislature were
even aware that this was happening so
one of the things it's part a
requirement in the bill is that when the
Attorney General receives a settlement
like this the fiscal committee is
actually notified of it and actually
receives a report around the amount of
the settlement the parameters of the
settlement uh and details like that what
the bill also uh allows is for
money uh to be
uh it it it it remains dependent on the
legislature to still appropriate money
to address this form of contamination
but once the money has been appropriated
um money will be able to be used from
this account to remediate that specific
kind of
contamination um the reason for
specifying that it's the kind of that
it's the contamination that's actually
addressed in the settlement is so we
don't run into a situation where where
we actually have people in New Hampshire
who've been harmed by one kind of
contamination but who find that money
received for the settlement to actually
help them out is actually being used uh
to address another form of contamination
in New Hampshire so the idea is let's
address the problem that the settlement
was received for first let's give that
first priority right um and then if we
have money left over if we find out that
well gee maybe the problem wasn't as bad
as we thought it was and maybe maybe
maybe there will be some money left over
in the settlement there's a mechanism in
the bill that would allow any remaining
money to be transferred over into two uh
other environmental funds uh the
drinking and groundwater trust fund and
the solid waste management fund um where
it could then also be applied to uh to
address environmental contamination in
the state but again it all comes down to
money that we get to remediate and
environmental contamination should be
used to remediate environmental
contamination it's pretty pretty simple
and uh and I hope uh I hope you find a
way to support it and I'll answer any
questions oh yes represent or thank you
Mr chairman and this may be a question
for Mr whims when he gets here I see him
waiting patiently uh uh for us but you
did mention it that was my thought when
when I saw this is the drinking water um
uh and groundwater trust fund and that
of course was related set up for another
chemical that we were polluted with why
wouldn't we just maybe combine you know
address the legislation or the statute
that defines that because there's a fair
amount of money in that as I as I am
made aware of um so rather than make yet
another fund Maybe
re address the parameters of that fund
so that we can put money through that I
I think part of what I what I was trying
to do with this I I know that there are
um I think the funds that are out there
um took time and Care uh to establish
and the and the advantage of them is
they're already established so if we
actually receive settlement money that's
supposed to go into those funds there's
nothing in this bill that would keep
that from happening happening so maybe
Pas wasn't the uh the best example
because money we receed for Pas
settlements uh would actually go into
the drinking and groundwater trust fund
right so there we really don't have to
do anything what what my bill does is
sort of address um what up until now I
think has been a fairly rare situation
where we actually receive a substantial
settlement uh for contamination that we
haven't accounted for in our law yet so
the idea is to just give that that money
a place to live until the legislature
can decide how it wants to spend it so
we're not taking away the
appropriation um ability of the
legislature the legislator's ability to
direct the money all we're doing is
we're saying hey let's hold it in a
specific fund until the legislature
figures out what it wants to do with it
once the legislature figures out what it
wants to do with it then the money can
start to be dispersed um and and I think
this is one of the areas where DHHS had
had some concerns is uh it's a little
unclear in the bill around who you know
which agency would actually be
responsible for that so I think that's
that's one of the things that we would
look to need uh you know look at need at
adding to the bill is to provide some
clarity around that but I I don't see
this as a statute that would be used a
lot um but I think it's just a based on
our experience with a PCB settlement it
would be a good thing to
have
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
representative this bill looks like it
it adds the word soil to this uh to
other to this effort and it seems to me
that we focused mostly on water and
drinking water and groundwater and I
don't know that I've ever seen anything
that says soil in this so this is
different than what we've seen before so
uh does that lend itself to combining
with any other uh uh trust fund that we
have thank
you um the answer to your question is I
don't
know this is this is where I think the
experts might be able to help us out um
the reason for putting soil in there is
um uh and and I wasn't able to actually
get uh an answer from the Attorney
General's office around the specific
reason why the PCB funds weren't put
into the drinking and groundwater trust
fund um but you know as as I as I looked
at it um I know that when we talk about
uh chemicals like pasas and things and
and chemicals of that nature for the
most part we're talking about water
contamination even though the meramac
situation it's also Airborne
contamination that gets into the soil
that contaminates the water it really
was just an effort on my part to be more
expansive around the types of
settlements that could be could be
entered I I also know that for from from
my own experience back in the late '70s
early 80s I was a reporter and I did
several news stories on uh on on PCB and
in particular I visited uh several uh
sites in New Hampshire uh where waste
pcbs were being stored basically imp
properly in leaking barrels uh and some
of the employees on those sites actually
had an acute condition called chloracne
which uh people can can get by actually
getting the chemical on their skin it's
self it develops a uh it it causes a
skin condition very similar to to acne
it's it's very uh quickly recognizable
so um I know that it's it's not just
water with pcbs it it is contaminated
soil and brown brown fields and things
nature represent El
me thank you
um I
do feel on that it's important to have
something I'm sorry I'm having I do feel
it it's important to have something more
generalized like this the one before it
for PC PF P seems to be only for four
towns and there are a lot of other towns
that have the P problem but um I wonder
in particular this the the Monsanto one
uh do we have methods for extracting
this from water or some other way to to
remediate What's Left of the problem at
this point and would that money just be
sitting there
for decades while we wait to be able to
solve it I am not an expert in
remediation of this this chemical I do
know that um I I actually live on
Sagamore Creek and there's PCB
contamination in the creek um and one of
the the things I asked someone from the
conservation law Foundation one time is
well what what should we do about that
and they said the best thing you can do
is not to disturb it so I think
sometimes we're in a situation like that
however um it's a good idea to have
people monitoring um that contamination
um there's fishing that takes place in
Sagamore Creek there's fishing that
takes place in Squam Lake and if those
if those chemicals work their way up the
biological food chain we want people to
be aware of the fact that um they're
putting themselves and their families
and anybody who eats that fish in danger
um uh if if the level of PCB is above a
certain level um so bottom line I I I
one of the things is I think it's
similar to pasas where it to actually
destroy PCB uh it takes an extremely
high temperature um so not not terribly
easy to do um but um $20 million is $20
million there just seems to have been
there there might have been something
else we could do other other than pay
for copy or paper and
toner uh there any pending lawsuits that
you know of right now that could yield
this sort of thing um I wish I did I
wish I would have known about this
one I think we all do or we we might
have been able to kind of get to a
different outcome and that's really what
the bill is for to answer your question
though I don't know of other lawsuits
that are out there right now okay all
right
right yes representa spillsbury thank
you Mr chairman so the bill basically
sets up a prioritization order where for
two years it's held for the specific
type of contaminant treatment got that
but it then defaults into these two
existing funds Solid Waste Management
fund and drinking water and groundwater
trust fund I don't know much about those
funds what's the current funding source
and what are the current balances in
those funds I don't know a lot about the
other um current funding mechanisms
either um so I'm not sure I'd be able to
help you there uh what I do know is that
money by those funds is used to
remediate environmental contamination
the reason for having that two-year
period is sometimes it can take a long
time for the legislature to agree on how
money should be appropriated and
sometimes we can't agree at all so the
the thing is is fighting contamination
in this state is urgent so what it it
basically does is set a 2-year period
perod where the legislature has time to
make that decision has time to direct
the funds um if at the end of that
period the the legislature either hasn't
directed the funds in a specific way or
if there are it has directed the funds
but there's money left over the money
would flow into those two other existing
funds where it could be used to
remediate other problems in the state so
the uh that's that's the
intent follow up okay so I think the
intent is clear I suppose I would want
to know more about the answers to the
two questions I posed before I thought
that was the right default step and you
know I don't know whether two years is
actually sufficient to earmark funds for
the specific
contaminant um but I just want to point
out incidentally I think there's some
language here that's going to trip us up
on line 30 of of uh page two the first
page of the bill
so what this sentence seems to do is
exclude certain settlements settlements
not included under the scope of this
section include dot dot
dot those eligible to be directed I
think that the language but are not
limited to has to be
struck be I because I don't think you
can construct an
exclusion that is not limited it eats up
the
whole and I think the reason for that
language was a little bit of an out on
my part because I wasn't sure if I had
captured um all of the existing
settlement funds which which means the
exclusions can be unlimited
yes so if that's something that the
committee would like to address and and
also my my guess is um uh Department of
Health and Human Services will have
okay uh represent elme just briefly did
you
uh see the fiscal note and did you um
look at what the Department of
Environmental
Services reservations are did I look at
the Department of Environmental Services
regulations on this I did not
reservations about it the reservations
they are they are saying that they worry
that uh money is going to be diverted
from uh other other um income coming
into de the intent the intent of the
bill is not to do that it's it's really
only to to give funds that are
undirected a place to go so they don't
get put into the general fund that
that's really what we're trying to do
here so what I what I tried to do was to
very
clearly uh separate any
um um uh any any provisions the
legislature has already made to direct
funds for specific type of contamination
into existing trust funds so what what I
did not want to do with this bill at all
was to get in the way of anything that's
already working um what I was trying to
do do do is to address the one thing
that appears not to be working thank
you okay thank you thank
you
to good morning Mr chair and honorable
members of the committee um at LSR
filing time representative Muse and I
both recognize the need for a bill such
as HB 16 1613 and both of us filed lsrs
with the same goal
I withdrew my LSR and I'm happy to
co-sponsor and testify to the merits of
this important bill establishing a Soil
and Water contamination settlement trust
fund for funds or proceeds received by
the Attorney General on behalf of the
state or its citizens as a result of any
civil judgment or settlement of a claim
suit petition or other action regarding
damages from environmental contamination
of soil and water makes good sense it
especially makes good sense to
communities who have found themselves
the unwitting victims of environmental
contamination
are living with the negative impacts of
environmental and public health
contamination they've neither caused nor
have the ability to stop and find that
the resources aren't available to take
all appropriate action I'll share a bit
about my community as the environmental
contamination experience there can be
extrapolated to reflect the experience
of other communities with other
contaminants I live in and represent the
town of marac the site of the largest
industrial environmental disaster in New
Hampshire's history related to the
production practices of a multi-billion
dollar multinational polluter St gobain
marac residents have been and will
continue to be greatly impact by
impacted by pest a group of man-made
toxins which such concerning
bioaccumulation and
biodegradation properties that they are
known as forever chemicals PS are known
to be linked to many negative Health
impacts and at least one of the 12 to
14,000 or so pest has recently been
proven to cause cancer with further
study I believe that other pfest will be
C found to cause the same or S similar
negative Health outcomes given a 42%
higher kidney cancer incidence than
would be expected my town is currently
the subject of a $500,000 kidney cancer
study for which in collaboration with
New Hampshire DHHS I filed legislation
to access funding the current study is a
phase three feasibility study which may
indicate a need for a more comprehensive
full epidemiological health study as one
might imagine health studies are
expensive and trying to access funding
for such important work given the many
competing needs we have in New Hampshire
can be challenging class action lawsuits
have been filed to address the public
health impacts of these dangerous
environmental contaminants to date New
Hampshire citizens living in pasas
impacted communities have been denied
medical monitoring and thus far at least
to my knowledge New Hampshire has not
received funding judgments or settl
specific to pest that could be used to
help address the significant and ever
increasing problems it has
created keeping the funds and proceeds
from legal action taken in response to
soil or water contamination distinct and
separate from all other state funds and
require they that they be deposited into
a designated trust fund ensures that the
funds received will actually be
available to address and remediate the
environmental contamination that
precipitated the legal action my
community and several others in Southern
New Hampshire would like to be able to
count on the availability of those funds
to address expenses and damages related
to the specific type of contamination
addressed by the settlement including
the remediation of the contamination
testing of soil and water for
contamination Health monitoring for
individuals at risk for or otherwise
impacted by the contamination and
further investigation by the Department
of Environmental Services relevant to
the specific type of contamination
addressed by the settlement
citizens have already paid millions of
dollars out of pocket to filter our
drinking water in schools filter public
water wells filter private wells and in
health care costs to address the health
impacts known to be associated with
environmental contamination please
ensure that the funds granted to the
state as a result of environmental
contamination litigation will truly be
available to specifically address the
issue by voting OTP on hb1 1613 thank
you for your
consideration thank you representative
PL may I have those notes you were
reading from sure I'll I'll I will be
happy to forward them to you everybody I
just have one sort of draft thank
you and just for the information of the
committee um after this I have two other
pink cards one from D HHS and Dees we'll
be hearing from both of those U areas
any questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
okay all right it's being it's it's
being recorded
so all right um let's
see in order that I receive the card so
DHHS
good afternoon thank you members of the
committee for the record my name is
Michelle robers and I'm the
administrator for the Bureau of Public
Health protection within the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services Division of Public Health
Services uh the department does not have
a position on this bill but does have
some
concerns regard regarding the
administrative responsibilities of the
proposed legislation the proposed Bill
amends New Hampshire RSA
126a which is the statute that provides
authority to the Department of Health
and Human Services as written HB 1613 is
not clear on determination of agency
administrative responsibilities related
to the proposed New Hampshire Soil and
Water contamination settlement fund the
proposed Bill does not provide an
appropriation to the Department to
support management of the trust fund and
does not provide any rul making
authority to establish um rules
pertaining to administration of the fund
uh the department recommends providing
Clarity on agency administration of the
trust fund and Associated Provisions for
implementation and in particular because
this trust fund is uh focused on
environmental contamination and we heard
from previous testimony about maybe the
funds being directed to uh provide and
um you know clean up of environmental
contamination uh the Department of
Environmental Services may be the more
appropriate agency to the over the
Department of Health and Human Services
while the Department of Health and Human
Services does H um oversee one uh
particular it's RSA 13A which uh is
childhood lead poisoning so there is um
Authority Under RSA 13A for the
Department to do investigations related
to to lead hazards that is really the
limit of what the department oversees in
terms of environmental contamination so
um we just ask that the committee
consider uh the purpose of the fund and
and maybe look at which agency is more
appropriate to oversee that
um that pretty much sums up my testimony
I'm happy to answer any questions and
I'm also happy to work with the bill
sponsor on any revisions uh to this to
seeing none thank you very much thank
you and the last pink card I have is
um
Adam I'm having trouble reading it so
nhdes good good afternoon members of the
committee uh my name is Adam kpo I'm the
assistant commissioner at the Department
of Environmental Services and I have uh
Mike at the director of the waste
division with me here today to help
answer some any technical questions you
might have um the Department's not
taking a position on this bill um the
bill would as you've heard establish a
trust fund to administer funding
obtained um from environmental
contamination Court settlements or
judgments um currently the department
administers many compliance enforcement
and Remediation
programs um that collect penalties and
recover costs for Environmental remed
mediation those funds are either
deposited into funds created in statute
or the general fund um as you heard from
uh previous speakers there there was a
PCB um settlement that went into the um
general fund and so um it just depends
on if there's a statutory mechanism for
that um the department believes that
this bill given the language in part
five would only uh affect funds that go
into the general fund uh
one concern that we did have is that the
bill is narrowly constricted so it would
require any funds received from a
judgment or a settlement to be used for
a specific type of contamination um
while in the case of PCB that was a
pretty large settlement but um there are
other ones that you know should in the
future we get anything they may be
smaller and either may not be enough or
too much or um whatever the case is so
we encourage the committee to provide
some flexibility there to be able to use
it on contamination generally should you
decide to move forward with the
bill
um it is UN as H DHHS spoke about
earlier um it's unclear which department
ad is administering this fund so I I
would encourage the committee to um you
know clear that up and if you decide to
move forward with the bill I would uh
strongly consider making it a non-aps
fund and continually appropriated so
those are really the general the the
gist of the comments in our testimony
letter um but happy to answer any
questions that you might have
representative shamber thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking this
question uh what is presently your
overall Mike do you think that's a good
question I always have that number
memorized when we're in budget but then
then then it leaves my brain it's uh I I
I don't want to guess I I don't know the
answer to that um I know just an answer
somewh I know that for my division it's
on the order of about $100
million um but for the Department it is
substantially greater than that because
we administer um not only do we the
division is only about one quarter of
the number of people in the department
but we also through our Water Division
and and through our waste division
administer um a a drinking water uh uh
State revolving fund and a clean water
State revolving fund that are
essentially like a $200 million bank so
it it it runs that number up in a way
that doesn't really reflect the
operations budget and we have all those
numbers we could certainly provide them
to you but I don't I don't want to
now oh yes representative
Malloy thank you um Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question earlier I
mentioned the word soil was added to
this um and we've I'm relatively
familiar with the water mitigation and
the pfoa and pfas U situations and that
um so I'm just posing this question and
I don't know that it's it's answerable
here but how does one mitigate the
soil the uh the the contaminants that
are in the soil I'm familiar with the
water and stuff that's my question sure
thank you for the question soil can
certainly be more challenging than water
um particularly it's in situ right so
unless you can either get some kind of a
treatment reagent into it in place or
dig it up and treat it um then it's hard
to do with water we usually treat water
either in a Wastewater setting at a
Wastewater Plant or in a drinking water
setting at a drinking water plant or in
the case of a individual home at a at a
treatment system within the home um so
so but soil is is I think appropriate
here in this case because in the case of
pcbs it is it is true that most most of
the contamination we have with respect
to pcbs in the state is associated
either with soil contamination or
sediments at the bottom of of our water
bodies because of the chemical nature of
pcbs and the way it's strongly absorbed
to soils and sediments we don't actually
have very many instances of groundwater
or drinking water contamination with
um
so you've indicated that you would
prefer not to have a constraint in the
first two years on the specific
contaminant but to to have more freedom
okay what is your view towards the
provision that then defaults unspent
funds at the end of two years into these
two specific existing
funds I don't think we have we have a
position on that or or the bill
specifically but um you know if if the
legis if it's the will of the
legislature to not appropriate funding
or there's a or there's not a mechanism
to if there's no agreement to
appropriate funding anywhere then maybe
there should it should lapse into
another um settlement fund such as the
drinking water groundwater trust fund or
something like
that yeah if I might add I I think it's
it's relevant to note because it's very
specific to what actually happened um
the the the the outsized response that
the agency has had to make with regard
to our discovery of past contamination
initially out at the Sea Coast at the
peas trade port and then a couple in
2014 and then two years later in 2016 in
Southern New Hampshire as a result of
some releases from some manufacturing
facilities um we had to act very quickly
like literally over the weekend when we
learned about that to go out and do a
lot of work to sample people's Wells to
do and we've done a tremendous amount of
work since that time which was eight
years now um the only reason we were
able to do that work is because we had
access to funding that gave us broader
um broader authority to use it most of
the funds that we used to do the initial
sampling and Analysis for pasas came
from the drinking water and groundwater
trust fund or from the MTB settlement
funds we were the MTB settlement funds
were directly related to mtbe but we
were able to pay for actual sampling of
Wells because we also could look at mtbe
and we would take an additional bottle
for pasas at that time in real time
using those funds and then for
analytical cost for pasas we were able
to access to drinking water and
groundwater trust fund all of those
funds that I just mentioned the MTB
settlement funds and the drinking water
groundwater trust fund came from a
lawsuit against Exxon Mobile and others
directly associated with mtbe so it was
very important that in the case
particularly of the drinking water
groundwater trust funds that we had the
authority to use them in a broader sense
for other contaminants because if we had
then just used those funds for mtbe at
that time when we had this complete
explosive crisis with respect to pasas I
don't think anybody would have been very
happy with us at that time but because
we had that ability to do that it made a
world of difference in how responsive we
were able to be to the Pas
crisis brief followup
so I think you're making a valuable
Point am I right in assuming that the
two funds specifically mentioned here
are both currently administered by
Dees they're entirely with agency that's
correct thank you and I apolog I always
wait for a question but if I might I
have to leave here in five minutes for
to be in another hearing that I cannot
miss I do want to add one point if I
might and that is that um because I
think it will help the committee
understand and I completely understand
representative M's reason for wanting to
do this the the circumstances surround
in the PCB lawsuit were somewhat unique
in the case of the um mtbe lawsuit we
knew that that money was coming we had a
lot of time the legislature talked about
that and in a full session was able to
develop and Implement a law that
established the drinking water and
groundwater trust fund so that money
would have a place and a mission when it
arrived at the agen at at the state in
the case of the PCB lawsuit it was
something that the Department of Justice
was working on um it happened very
quickly surpris even them how fast the
settlement came and there was
essentially no time to do that kind of
process that was done with the uh uh
with the with the with the mtbe lawsuit
so I'm not here to present or take a
position on the way to approach that in
the future I think it's a it's a valid
concern but I just want you to
understand there's a significant
difference between what happened with
the PCB lawsuit and and what happened
when we had that we knew that that mtbe
coming
representative one other question Mr oh
I'm
sorry I'm wondering if if we had these
uh this past and we had the three funds
if you would um run into problems with
receiving a new settlement coming in and
not really knowing which partt to put it
in or would you be faced with like oh do
we put like 50% here and 50% there I I
think depending on how the language is
drafted this this fun I think the intent
from represented Muse is to this to be a
catchall for what isn't currently in
statute so if it's not current currently
catchall yes A new a new settlement that
isn't already accounted for in statute
somewhere so in the case of PCB we
didn't have a PCB remediation fund
established and so it wouldn't have gone
into into that um or or there wasn't a
place for it to go so it Go went into
the general fund um this would be catch
anything that would currently go into
the general
fund just can I just follow up on that
I'm just thinking about if something if
a settlement comes in and it impacts
water and it impacts soil and how you
know you drinking water all it could it
could impact all of those things how
what would you do sure I it's a great
question I I think the the answer is is
that depends on the lawsuit and depends
on the legal action if the lawsuit of
the legal action is taken under an
existing state statute that already says
money goes to a certain place then it
would be clear where that would have to
go for example in the case of the PCB
lawsuit I I don't remember all the
details but my recollection is that that
was essentially a nuisance claim there
was no underlying State Environmental
statute where that was being used to
advance that lawsuit so as a result when
the settlement occurred there was no uh
controlling statute that would tell you
here's where that money ought to go so
when that happens when there's nothing
there it defaults to go to the general
fund so to answer your question I think
uh if a lawsuit like that were moved
forward that was again under a general
nuisance claim or some other legal
theory that wasn't tied to a State
Environmental statute then it would
likely go if it was about contamination
it would likely go to this fund if this
fund were created right a new a new
settlement right
representative shamberg followed by
represent oh is he first okay
representative Malloy thank you thank
you very quickly P Money where would
that go if
we get that I I don't believe as I think
probably most people here know there's a
there's a there are pending lawsuits
against the manufacturers of pasas that
may take quite some time to reconcile
but assuming that they do and that
there's some award that comes to the
state um I don't think this bill would
impact that because there's already a
lot of law on the books that say exactly
where that money will go if and when
those settlements or or verdict money
would come in
thank Senator CH thank you Mr chairman
thank you I'll get you out of here real
quick at the end of your Mo historically
end of your budget
years do you have Surplus money left
over um that's a complex question on the
general fund side there's certainly
money that lapses and in fact um in many
cases we're directed to have a lapse
have money left over that will go back
to the to the to the um State's coffers
with respect to the um the kinds of uh
dedicated funds that we've been talking
about here most of those are
continuously appropriated and non-lps so
they they go over to the next bium they
don't revert to the state
cence representative ORS thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question you
say you're directed to put the money
back to make sure you have money to put
back in the general enal fund I'm not
quite understanding that uh typically
you know uh I don't know if you want to
answer that typically the the governor's
office is is you know as the head of the
Executive Branch is looking to make sure
that that all that everything works out
financially for the state and they may
have in a particular year a need for a
certain amount of money to come back and
and what often happens is you know for
example I don't want to get too detailed
but in the case of permanent full-time
positions those are budgeted in class 10
and if you have any vacancies during the
during the year you're going to have
extra money in that that money is not
suddenly ever they never tell us oh you
can use that for something else if you
want to that money always lapses back to
the to the state which as it should so
follow thank you so I take it so it's
not impacting what you're trying to do
in terms of your day-to-day operations
or
whatever I'm sorry what's not impacting
the money going back to the general fund
it's not it's not taking out of what you
need money for not typically no okay
thank
you and I do apologize I I do have to
step away representative
roord thank you Mr chairman and I'm glad
we got somebody staying because I've got
a question hopefully you can answer this
for me and and I think the the point of
this bill is really to get the money
that's going to the people that it's
supposed to go to and and and and and I
think that I hope we can all agree that
that's that's that's a good cause um so
I guess I know we have the drinking
water and groundwater trust fund which
that was already there it's already
existed if I wonder if you could just
describe to me a little bit because
having been here a year I've only been
here a year things move slow here and
you know I I I I think sometimes that
I in and in context of getting the money
to where it needs to go we want to get
it there as fast as we can as well so in
that context could you describe a little
bit how the drinking water and
groundwater trust F works I know there's
a commission or committee it's got 10 or
12 people on it what's the process of
getting and I think there's a lot of
money in this fund quite a bit actually
uh right now um and so how what's the
process of getting that money to the
people that need it and to making sure
it goes to the the Urgent acute needs um
you know and I and I say that in the
context of you know I understand what
the point of the bill is but I I don't
want to reinvent the wheel I want to
make sure we're getting the money where
it needs to go as quick as we can get it
sure sure so uh in in the case of the
drinking water groundwater trust fund
there is a drinking waterw trustman
advisory commission that makes recommend
uh
that helps establish the budget you know
the commissioner of the Department of
Environmental Services and and various
other entities there are some State reps
on there right now representative Bill
Boyds the the chair um they they help
decide where this money goes and and
what the what the emerging needs are and
what it would might be eligible for um
and then once that is in place uh and
they decide that then it goes through um
Governor councel the governor councel
process and and sort of the pro the uh
mission of state government if you will
so um I can get more information on that
more detailed information on how those F
what pockets of funds there are um and
exactly where where those funds go if
you'd like but that's from a 30,000 foot
view how that works follow follow thank
you um so I guess also looking at
timeline I mean are we talking you know
so if I if I find out the well of my
backyard has mtbe microplastics past
whatever it may be in it and I need a
new well and that's determined you know
it fits the criteria and I can go to
this board and say hey because I think
we've replaced two Wells this year uh
you know I think it came from arpa funds
but I think eventually this fund will be
getting hit quite a
bit point being is how quickly once I
file a claim am I going to get help is
this going to be years is it going to be
weeks is it going to be months it
depends on the the program there are
several programs within the drinking
water groundwater trust fund that that
are administered and and the board helps
decide where those go um you know and so
we got a pretty large settlement from
the Exon Mobile case um that's that's in
the fund and you know it's really
determining how much can be done each
year because a lot of these funds go to
um Grant there some of them are grants
some of them are uh loans that come back
and and with that we get uh interest on
those loans so it so as to keep you know
recycling the funding and you know
moving forward so it really depends on
on what program you might be talking
about the um we we had a program
regarding uh droughts and being able to
drill new wells um if you're if your
well went dry and you uh met some income
requirements you so you may that may be
what you're referring to but um but it
just depends on the program and which
program you're applying for and all of
that and which programs are still open
to apply for I have one more problem
sure thank you um so the the uh actually
it was a p I think there was a well in
Canterbury and maybe out on the western
side of the state two Wells were
replaced uh because of contamination um
so the legislation that's being proposed
and maybe this is a question for the
sponsor how would that would would it
take an act of Congress an act of
legislature if the money gets dumped
into that trust fund an additional Act
of this body to get the money out so I
again the way I I can't I'm not clear
when reading it so I want to make sure
we have the easiest access to this that
we can yeah my understanding based on
the language is that the general court
would need to uh administer the fund and
and decide where those funds go the
agency wouldn't be the one under the
bill to do that um so that's it would
take an act of the legislature if you
will um I don't know I think uh
representative you mentioned the fiscal
the fiscal committee at one point I'm
not sure if that was the intent but I
know it would be the as it now would be
an act of the general
absolutely anything else any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you and I'd like to just
offer uh you know the department to be
available to to help with any amendments
or um any technical questions from the
thank all right I don't see any others
out there to testify so I will close the
1613 okay we have concluded uh our work
today and um look forward to seeing you
a.m. all our public hearings are done we
had 25 bills came to Ways and Means at
this point we've had a public hearing on
every single one and starting on Monday
sessions thank you I mean Monday will be
work sessions only Tuesday will be work
execs okay it's out
good oh so that actually that is the
list representative fellows you would
okay here I'll give you this
pile
cards oh we're only we're only an hour
bad my
stach
though
e